Tim Ferriss:
Hello, boys and girls, ladies and germs. This
is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another episode of
The Tim Ferriss Show. My guest today is James
Clear. You can find him on Twitter and Instagram,
@jamesclear. James is a writer and speaker,
focused on habits and continuous improvement.
He is the author of the number one New York
Times mega bestseller, I'm adding the mega,
Atomic Habits, which covers easy and proven
ways to build good habits and break bad ones.
The book has sold more than 10 million copies
worldwide and has been translated into more
than 50 languages. On average, Atomic Habits
has sold one copy every 15 seconds since it
was published. By the time I finish reading this
intro, two or three copies will have been sold.
James is also the creator of the 3-2-1 Newsletter.
That's three, dash, or I suppose, hyphen, two,
hyphen, one newsletter, which is one of the
most popular email newsletters in the world
and has more than two million subscribers. Each
issue contains three short ideas from James,
two quotes from other people, and one question
to consider that week. We're going to talk a lot
about questions, in fact, shortly with James.
You can sign up for free at jamesclear.com.
He is a regular speaker at Fortune 500 companies
and his work is used by players and coaches in
the NFL, NBA, and MLB. In college he was
an academic all-American baseball player
and he is an avid weightlifter. For those
who cannot see the video, we seem to go to
the same stylist. We've got the same handsome
bald look and the same long sleeved dark shirt
look. You can find James at jamesclear.com and, as
mentioned, on Twitter and Instagram @jamesclear.
James, it is nice to see you.
James Clear: Hey, great to talk to
you. Thank you so much for the opportunity.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. I'm thrilled to be
having this conversation. I thought we would
start with something that's also on my mind,
but the topic of annual reviews comes up for
some people once a year and we are now winding
down on this year, about to head into the new
year. Could you please describe your annual
reviews and perhaps just walk us through the
process, and also describe or explain why,
for at least a period of time, you
published all of these publicly.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: You
can tackle that in any order you'd like.
James Clear: It's nice to have a process for
reflection and review. I'm sure we'll talk a lot
about habits in this conversation, and one of the
meta habits that's really helpful is some kind of
habit of reflection and review because it allows
you to course correct. Nobody sets out to get off
course or to make a mistake or to do something
that goes against their values, but we just have
this natural drift in life. As time goes on, we
find ourselves in situations where maybe we're not
doing the optimal thing anymore. An annual review
is a chance to check in. I also think it's helpful
to have shorter cycles of review. On Fridays,
I usually do some kind of short little business
review, where I look at revenue and expenses and
new email subscribers and stuff like that.
But at the end of each year, I like to ask
myself some big questions. Actually, I'm glad you
started here because I think that questions can be
very useful. If you ask better questions, you can
get better answers. But also, questions are very
resilient, they're very adaptable to the context.
That's something that's different, and perhaps a
little bit better, than advice. Advice is actually
brittle and context dependent. Somebody can have a
really good plan, a really good piece of advice to
give you, but if it doesn't fit your context, then
it's actually not great advice for your particular
situation, whereas questions are very adaptable.
I think maybe what I should do is just go
through some of the questions that I like
to ask myself for my annual review
and throughout the rest of the year.
I guess we could say this first category is just
questions that help improve self-awareness or
help bring me back to center. The first thing,
and I think actually this might be a question
from Derek Sivers or some version of it from him,
"Just what am I optimizing for?" Sometimes people
optimize for money, sometimes they optimize for
free time, sometimes they optimize for creative
output or being able to choose the projects they
work on, all kinds of stuff, but that answer
probably changes over time. What I'm optimizing
for today is different than what I was optimizing
for five years ago or 10 years ago. I think it's
a helpful question to keep revisiting. You need
to decide what it is for you, otherwise it's easy
to slide into this status signaling or just doing
the things that you feel like you're encouraged to
do by society or by your friends or peers or your
parents or whatever. What am I optimizing for?
Another way of phrasing that is maybe, "What's the
real objective here? What am I actually trying
to achieve?" Some version of that question.
I also like, "Does this activity fill me with
energy or drain me of energy?" You can tell
a lot just by whether it fills up your cup or
not. Ideally, you'll be spending more time in
the next year on things that fill you with energy
and less time on things that drain you of energy.
Speaking of the things that drain you, maybe
a sub-question that I like to keep in mind is,
"Does the amount of attention I'm giving this
match its true importance?" Man, there's so many
years when I find that I'm giving something a lot
of attention that actually is not that important.
It's nice to check in and course correct that.
Tim Ferriss: Are you asking these questions as
you're going through the calendar
of your past year? In what set
of circumstances or in what context are
you asking these questions or these just
broadly speaking questions that you're
applying more or less all the time for
self-awareness and different types of cycles?
James Clear: Well, I don't think you need to
wait and only do it once a year, but when I
am asking these questions for the end review,
I usually am writing maybe a paragraph for each
one. It's almost like a journaling prompt. I do
have things that I check for this process.
There's a lot of measurement, so to speak,
that happens throughout the year, even if you
aren't thinking about it that way. For example,
my calendar measures how many new cities I
went to or how many nights I spent away from
home, and those are important things.
Tim Ferriss: How do you do that?
Oh, I see. It measures it, meaning it logs it.
James Clear: Right. I can see, oh, I was in
Dallas from Tuesday to Thursday, so because
I know that I was there then I'm like, "Well,
that was two nights or three nights where I wasn't
sleeping in my own bed." Then at the end of the
year I try to figure out how many nights did I
spend away from home, is that more than I want to
spend? Is it less? How did that fall for the year?
Or I write down my workouts in an actual journal,
like a pen and paper journal. I've got all the
sets logged, I have how many workouts I did. Then
I can look back on the dates, how many workouts
did I do for each month, what was the average
number of workouts per month? A lot of that stuff,
I'm not thinking about tracking it throughout
the year, but it's there for me as I sit down to
review the year. Those measurements are there as
I'm going through these questions and then trying
to figure out where did I direct my attention,
what am I optimizing for, am I spending my energy
on things that fill me up or things that drain me?
Tim Ferriss: Perfect.
James Clear: Another question that
I think is helpful is once you answer what
am I optimizing for, you can ask yourself,
"Can my current habits carry me to my desired
future?" That's really about figuring out
what kind of trajectory you're on. If they
can, then maybe all you need is patience,
but if they can't, something needs to change,
you need to develop or build some new habits.
Another question I love, and this is actually at
the core of a lot of what I talk about in Atomic
Habits, is "How can I create an environment that
will naturally bring about my desired change?"
Rather than trying to fight this and force my way
through, rather than trying to grit my teeth and
make it happen even if the circumstances aren't
ideal, how can I look around and structure my
physical environment, my social environment and
the tribes I'm a part of and my strategy for what
I'm trying to achieve so that it's almost
natural that I'm moving in that direction?
I actually have a bunch of questions. I've got
like 20 that I go through, but those are just
three or four that come to mind.
Tim Ferriss: Well, we may come
back to the remainder of the list because I am a
question junkie, no big surprise there.
But I wanted to maybe reference, I shouldn't
say the, but one of the key points in the first
chapter of Atomic Habits, which is you don't rise
to the level of your goals, you fall to the level
of your systems, which is a modification of one
of my favorite quotes, I wish I could actually
speak the original language, but I cannot, alas,
from the Greek poet and philosopher, Archilochus,
"We don't rise to the level of our expectations,
we fall to the level of our training."
To the systems piece,
I think about this a lot and have found for myself
and certainly for many people in my audience, that
stacking the deck so it is harder to fail goes
a lot further than trying to rely on willpower.
It's almost difficult for me to imagine precise
steps you could take to hone something that is
labeled as broadly as willpower. How can you set
up accountability, how can you set up incentives,
et cetera? What are some of the systems that
you have for yourself for various habits?
James Clear: We can pick a couple different
habits. Let's take fitness for example,
and then I'll also do it for writing and business.
For fitness, this is one of my core habits,
it's one of the ones I feel like is most
important for how I structure my day,
but I try to do whatever I can to reduce friction
and make it as easy as possible to do it.
The first thing is I give myself permission to
reduce the scope but stick to the schedule. If
my typical workout takes 45 minutes, but I
only have 15 that day, it's easy to get into
this story where you're like, "Ah, I don't have
time to do it all, why bother?" But instead,
I try to remind myself to reduce the scope but
stick to the schedule. There have been a lot of
days where all I have time for is to go in and do
a couple sets of squats, but I'm glad that I did
that rather than doing nothing. It counts for
a lot to not throw a zero up for another day.
In a sense, in the long run, I
almost feel like the bad days
matter more than the good days because —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I agree with that.
James Clear: — if you show up on the bad days,
even if it's less than what you had hoped for,
you maintain the habit. If you maintain
the habit, then all you need is time.
It counts for a lot. You also proved to
yourself, you can look at yourself in the
mirror at the end of the night and be like,
"You know what? Circumstances weren't ideal,
situation wasn't perfect, but I still found out a
way to show up and get some reps in today." That's
the first thing, it's mindset and approach.
Second thing is, and I've gradually increased
what I do for this, first there's basic stuff like
set your workout clothes, set them out the night
before, have everything ready to go, have your
water bottle filled up, stuff like that, but I've
gradually reduced the friction even more. I used
to work out at a gym for 10 years and so I would
do all that kind of stuff, now, over the last year
or two, I've built a home gym. All I have to do is
get down to the basement and I can just work out
there. I'm gradually accumulating more and more
equipment, I'm becoming this equipment hoarder,
but now I have enough stuff that I don't have any
excuses. All I have to do is just walk downstairs
and I can be doing that exercise in 15 seconds.
It's really just about reducing friction.
Some of that is strategy too. If you don't
have equipment or you don't want to pay for a gym
membership, there are great body weight programs
or you could just do 10 sprints up and down the
sidewalk. They are almost no excuses if you have
the right strategy for reducing friction and just
figuring out ways to get a decent workout in.
Tim Ferriss: I think the reduction of scope
that you mentioned is really critical,
that if you don't have time for 60 it doesn't
mean you have to go to zero. I'm guilty of, this
happens to me sometimes, I'm not going to lie. But
I will also just add, if you don't have space for
an entire gym, you almost certainly have space for
a functional doorstop, aka a kettlebell. You could
get one kettlebell or even build a kettlebell
from some basic materials, people can look it up,
a T-bar kettlebell for swings. If you can just
do one set of swings, you're going to hit a lot.
I would love to hear, well, let's see,
a few things, if you don't mind me
just adding my commentary.
James Clear: Yeah, sure.
Tim Ferriss: The first is underscoring
another thing you said, which is,
I don't want to say it doesn't matter, but it
matters much less what happens on the days where
you feel like doing the things that you have
set out as your habits or goals, behaviors,
et cetera. What matters is what happens when
you don't want to do those things. This is
where the systems and the lack of excuses
and accountability and so on comes into play.
How do you apply this — well, actually, one more
thing, which is the exercise piece. I'm glad you
brought up first. Many people might think,
"Well, that's fine, that's just exercise,"
but exercise for me is the cascading upper level
of the waterfall. If you take care of your body,
your body takes care of your brain and mood
and so many other things. In a sense it's the
force multiplier category, so I'm glad we
spoke about it first. What other types of
systems, and I'll put that in air quotes because
it could take, I'm sure, a lot of different forms,
but what might be examples of systems or
scaffolding that you've set up in other areas?
James Clear: Yeah. Just a quick point
on what you just mentioned first.
I think it's worth asking yourself what habits
are upstream from other things that I want to
do or other things that set me up for a good day.
What you're describing is that a workout habit, at
least for you, and I would say for me, is upstream
from a lot of other good things that happen. I
get the benefits of the workout, sure, but also, I
tend to have that post-workout high for an hour or
two where I get this good period of concentration.
I tend to eat better when I'm training,
it's like I don't want to waste it. It's actually
when I'm not training that I get lazy and start
eating whatever I want. I tend to sleep better at
night because I'm tired from the workout, which
means I wake up the next day and I have better
energy. At no point was I trying to actively
build better sleep habits or nutrition habits or
whatever, but it just came as a natural byproduct
of getting that one habit of a good workout in.
It doesn't have to be fitness. You talk to some
people, comedians for example or athletes, will
talk about how they have this visualization habit
before they step out on the stage. If they get
that in, they recite what a good performance is
going to look like, that helps them perform in
the moment. Or CEOs will talk about a meditation
habit, and if they get their 15 minutes of
meditation in in the morning, that sets them
up for the rest of the day being productive.
I think it just comes down to asking yourself,
when I'm living a good day, when I'm on, what are
some of the key habits that are part of that? Then
maybe rather than worrying about everything and
trying to hit every little domino along the way,
what's the lead domino? What's that
first action that's upstream from the
other productive things? Can I just pour my
energy into making sure I do that today and
trust that the momentum will carry me forward?
Okay, so your question was, what are some other
examples of systems? It can take many different
forms. It could be a physical thing that helps
you be more productive. For example, this doesn't
work for everybody's job, but it works for mine,
and I don't do it every day, but I probably do it
70 to or 80 percent of the time, which is I leave
my phone in another room until lunch each day.
Now, it gives me a chance, it gives me space,
to just work on my agenda rather than responding
to everybody else's agenda. I can actually show
up and have a few hours where I can do some
creative work. That's a system in a sense,
it's a physical environment that promotes or
benefits the habit that I'm trying to build,
which is creative output or writing or whatever.
It could be digital things. For example, each week
I write 3-2-1, this weekly newsletter. There are
three short ideas from me, two quotes from other
people and one question in each newsletter. I have
a spreadsheet that has three tabs, one of them is
ideas, one of them is quotes, and one of them is
questions. I've got hundreds of ideas that I've
generated or quotes that I've run across and read
or questions that I've spitballed and been, "Oh,
maybe this could be in a newsletter sometime."
Because I have this system, which in this case
is just this spreadsheet of raw material, it only
takes me an hour or two to write the newsletter
because I have a lot to start from, I have good
starting material. The system of when I read a
book and come across a quote that I like, I type
it down and put it into the spreadsheet, that's
a very simple system, but it makes the process
of writing the newsletter each week much easier.
There are many different forms that could take,
it could be almost infinite in its variations,
but it's any way that you set up the
environment, physical, digital or social,
to make the habit easier and more frictionless.
Tim Ferriss: Let's zoom in on the creative
process a little bit. We're going to talk
about also email lists, building email,
because I feel as though what was old is once
new again. Always, it's like every few years
I have to be like, "Guys, you need a way to
communicate with your audience that cannot be
taken away from you immediately by a platform."
I don't know how many times I've had to say this.
James Clear: Yeah, email never dies,
but everybody talks about how it's dead.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. It's like the cat came
back the very next day, we thought it was a goner,
but it wouldn't stay away. Email is not going
anywhere anytime immediately. We'll come back to
that, because it is a vehicle for transmitting
some of this creative work as you described.
I have read a bit about your use, or past use,
of Asana for capturing ideas. I think this was
for asymmetry at the time, at least in the article
I read on every.to. Then I separately read about
a 600-page Google Doc that you had put together
and were compressing in various ways. Where have
you landed with idea capture, maybe web capture,
let's add that in because it may be a separate
category, what is your portfolio of tools?
James Clear: First of all, I don't think the tool
matters that much. I think what does matter is
crafting great information flows and capturing the
good ideas that you come across. Then depending on
what you're trying to do, in my case, I'm trying
to create books or to write newsletters,
using that raw material that you collected
to create something great. I would say the big
picture game is always the same, which is first
I'm trying to craft better information flows.
Almost every idea that you have is downstream from
what you consume. We don't usually think about
it that way, but when you choose who to follow on
Twitter, you're choosing your future thoughts in a
sense, you're creating the information flow, what
the timeline, what the feed is going to look like.
Or when you choose what book to read or which
podcast episode to listen to, you're choosing the
thoughts that are going to arise. Now, you may not
necessarily know what they are, but over time you
can start to learn which sources of information
are higher signal than others. I almost feel like
that is the main habit to try to build, especially
in our current modern society, because information
is overflowing and so widely accessible.
Tim Ferriss: So choosing your inputs.
James Clear: The person who creates better
information flows, gets better thoughts.
Tim Ferriss: How do you consume?
What do you choose?
James Clear: I've spent an
unreasonable amount of time curating my Twitter
feed. I think that makes me feel better about
spending time on it. I'm not necessarily saying
it's the best place, but because I have found a
really good set of people to follow I do get
useful ideas from Twitter. It's easy and I'm
probably spending more time on it than I should,
so at least now maybe it's a little more valuable.
But the single highest thing for me is when
I find a book that is relevant to what I'm
writing about. If it's relevant to the topic,
and I mean that in a more granular fashion,
let's say for Atomic Habits for example. I
don't mean a book about habits, I mean, hey,
I'm writing a chapter on self-control and this
book has a story that relates to self-control,
or this book has a piece of research that relates
to that particular chapter, when I find the right
thing, it's hard for me to even get through a page
because I'm taking so many notes and it's sparking
so many ideas to write about. It'll take me an
entire morning just to get through three pages.
Tim Ferriss: How do you find the gems that
are that dense? I have my own thoughts on how
I approach this, but there are a hundred
thousand plus books published a year in
the US in English alone, probably, something
along those lines. How do you ferret your way
through the maze to find some of those books?
James Clear: I think the first thing is you've
got to be willing to quit books fast. If
you have baggage around finishing books,
if you feel like you have to finish something
because you started it, then you're just
going to be stuck and you won't move on quickly
enough. There's this quote about Emerson, I think,
where it says something like, "He read like
a hawk looking for prey, scanning over the
field." I think about that, I try to read
like that. I'm not reading for the enjoyment
or slowly unpacking a book the way that I would
with a sci-fi novel or something. It's like I'm
trying to find an insight. That's the first
thing, is start more books, quit most of them.
The second thing is suggestions from friends are
always helpful. If you let people know, "Hey,
I'm writing about this topic. What's the good book
that I should read?" I have found a couple great
ones that way, so just putting it out into the
universe. If you find a book that's good, go to
the back of the book and see what the references
are, and then go through those and just scan those
books on Amazon and a lot of the time you'll find
a couple other ones that are useful. If you find a
book that had something but you feel like maybe
it didn't quite hit it, go to Amazon and check
all the three-star reviews for that book, or the
one-star reviews sometimes, and there'll be other
books recommended in there. They'll say, "Instead
of reading this, you should read this one."
Tim Ferriss: The three-star reviews is
a key, because the five-star reviews are
just overly — not overly, I don't want to slam
five-star reviews, I love five-star reviews,
but they tend to not — I would say, for me at
least, one-star reviews are sometimes like,
"I ordered a toaster and they sent me a book," and
you're like, "Aw, come on. You bought a book. Pay
attention to what you're clicking."
James Clear: Sure, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: But the three-star reviews, the
most helpful or most critical three-star reviews,
you tend to get a lot of really helpful feedback.
I'll add too, for folks who might just be curious,
because I read, for people who can see behind
me, I have bookshelves and many, many more
bookshelves, I'll very often go to Wikipedia and
Goodreads, I will see if the book is old enough,
and if it's iconic enough or has stood the test
of time, which is not true for all books that
I've read or do read, but there will often be a
Wikipedia page and there will almost always be
quotes from fill in the blank book, Goodreads,
if you search that on Google you'll get a
good selection. You can get a feel for, for
instance, Finite and Infinite Games by Carse,
is that something you want to read? Well, you
could get a very good taste of it. It's like if
you don't like the trailer for the movie, you're
not going to like the movie. If you don't like
the Goodreads highlights, you're not going
to like the book, I can almost guarantee you.
Side note on that, you were mentioning, what
am I optimizing for, which sounds very much
like it could be a Derek Sivers' question, he
has a lot of good questions. A variant on that
that I've also found helpful is, "What game am I
playing?" We're all playing games, so it's like
aside from shelter, food, a handful of the basics
at the very bottom of Maslow's Hierarchy of Needs,
we're all playing games. What games are you
playing? What are you trying to win? Becoming
cognizant of that is, for me at least, step one.
James Clear: I think, I don't know if this is a
question that you've asked before, but is that
game worth winning? Is this something that —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely.
James Clear: Am I climbing the right
mountain or do I need to be climbing a different
one? Because it's very important to make sure
that you're in the right game.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
You mentioned the tools not mattering so much,
choosing the inputs, we talked about books.
For capturing, when you're like,
"That's good, that's good, that's good."
James Clear: You're right, I do use Asana mostly.
It's a very messy process and Asana's just a
holding ground for it, but I have the app on my
phone and Ive got it pulled up on my browser all
the time and so it's always right there. I don't
really care what the tool is, in this case this
is what I've been using for the last few years,
but it just needs to be something that is always
present and as soon as you have an idea, it
always goes into one place. You don't have
to think about where you're going to record it and
you don't end up with a random note on your iPhone
and another one in an Evernote doc and a third
thing in a Google Doc, and now it's hard to find
the ideas. If you have them all in one place —
Tim Ferriss: That sounds like the story of my
life right now, which is why I'm very interested
in your use of Asana, because I've used Asana to,
I still use Asana for project management, task
management, but idea capture wasn't a use case
I'd really considered. Would you mind, just for
people listening, explaining? I know this is
going to seem very pedestrian, but how
do you it without stuff getting lost?
James Clear: Part of this is, again, I'm
trying to simplify things as much as possible,
and we may talk about this more as we go through
the conversation, but I have a really small team,
it's me and one employee. I'm not interested in
having a large team and I want to be as effective
and as high leverage as possible. That means
that we need to think really carefully about
where we spend our time. If I always have a bunch
of different tools or I'm always switching between
different apps, that's just time that's wasted
if the job could be done in the same place.
We use Asana to run the book launch or to run
the newsletter calendar or to for all the other
stuff that we do throughout the day, and so I
was like, "Well, I can write it down here just
as well as I can write it down somewhere else."
Then once it gets categorized, it goes into the
appropriate doc for that project. As an example,
let's say I'm reading a book and I come across an
idea that's relevant for the newsletter and
it's a quote. I'll probably label the task
or the project of the new thing that I put into
Asana, I guess they usually call them tasks, but
I label things based on the project it's going to.
I'll just say, "Quote," and then I'll paste the
quote in and then it's labeled. I'll go through
all those quotes, or Lindsay, my employee, will
go through all those quotes and we'll put them
into the spreadsheet so they're in the right tab.
Or let's say the next thing I'm reading, I come
across an idea that sparks a thought for me,
where I'm like, "Oh, that would fit into the next
chapter for the book." I'll write the idea out and
then I'll label it based on whatever the topic
of the book is. For Atomic Habits, the label
might be Habits. At the beginning of any idea
I come across that would fit for the book, I'll
put Habits. Then a lot of the time I'll actually
put a second category for the chapter. Let's say
that this particular idea was for the chapter
on self-control, it'll be Habits, Self-Control,
and then I'll type the idea out. Then a couple
times a week I'll go through everything that's
labeled as Habits and then put it in the right
place in the doc and then it's all there.
You could imagine one way to do this even faster,
which is you could just put it straight into the
doc that it needs to live in. Instead of putting
it into Asana, I could put it straight into the
3-2-1 Newsletter sheet or I could put it
straight into the chapter for the book,
but I've noticed that the problem is I've got a
lot of projects going at one time and a lot of
notes from places where things could live. If I'm
always having to remember which thing to pull up,
then you either end up with a bazillion tabs
open or it just is hard to remember which
things need to go where at the exact moment
when you have the idea. A lot of the time,
I'll have an idea when I'm on a walk or in the
middle of a workout, and so I'm not in a position
to pull up the book manuscript, I just need to be
able to get it down and then I can sort it later.
Tim Ferriss: For people listening, what I'm
trying to do in this conversation, we'll see
how successful it is, is to zoom in and zoom out.
We'll zoom out and we'll talk about the conceptual
framework or a particular focal point, whether
it's within, say, the Atomic Habits paradigm or
outside of it, just given what you focus on James,
and then zoom in so we can take a look at how does
James run systems or develop systems in location X
in his life. The one-employee small team is where
I'd like to go next if that's okay with you.
James Clear: Sure, yep.
Tim Ferriss: How do you, I suppose, try to build
systems, ensure maximal leverage, with a very
small team? This is always of interest to me. I
have a small team, it has always been of interest
to me, like Small Giants by Bo Burlingham. I
think the subtitle is Companies That Choose
to Be Great Instead of Big or something like
that. I've always been fascinated by positive
constraints. One you could set is I'm not going
to have a big team, I'm not going to hire a
lot of people. Then you have to make decisions
that fall in line with not optimizing for that,
but operating within that constraint.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: What are some of
the productivity principles,
guiding questions, and so on that you have?
James Clear: First, I'll just say I'm not saying
this is how everybody should run their business,
it's just how I choose to run mine. You have to
choose what you're trying to accomplish. In
my case, I don't want to have a big team,
but I do want to make as big of an impact as
possible. The first question I ask is rather
than optimizing for money, let's optimize for
time, so how do I want to spend my days? Then
I try to make as few choices as possible that
violate that answer. You've got to keep coming
back to that. How do I want to spend my days? What
do I want my time to be spent on? Within that,
how can we reach the most people possible or make
the most money possible, but not without violating
that, because there's all kinds of things you do.
I could staff up, I can build a bigger business,
whatever, but I'm not interested in spending
my days like that. That's the first thing,
is you've got to decide what you're trying to do.
A question that I love and that I keep coming
back to for increasing leverage, and I try
to encourage both Lindsay and I to think
about this over and over again, is: what is the
work that keeps working for us once it's done?
As an example, when Atomic Habits came out, I did
a ton of interviews. Some of those interviews were
on radio, and I don't really do radio interviews
anymore because as soon as I get done with that
10-minute segment or whatever it was, all the
work that I put in it vanishes. Nobody's listening
anymore, it's off the air. Whereas a podcast,
what we're doing right now, is being recorded
and so people can continue to listen to it. I've
done a bunch of podcasts for the book and there's
somebody somewhere listening to one of them right
now. It's almost like there are multiple versions
of James out there and they're all continuing
to work right now. That's an example of the
work that keeps working for you once it's done.
If you can do one or two things a day that are
going to keep working for you in the long
run, man, you end up two or three or five
years later and you just have this tidal wave
of previous effort that is working for you.
So let me give you a couple different examples
and stories from my personal experience.
I wrote this article a couple years ago, it
was called "The Physics of Productivity," and
it was just taking like Newton's three laws and
applying them to productivity in kind of this,
I don't know, hopefully clever way. And it did
fine. The article didn't blow up or anything,
but it was just kind of a normal piece. And
it sat there on the site and people would
occasionally read it. And then a couple years
later, this journalist from the New York Times
read that article and they were writing this
piece and they linked to the original article
in it. And it wasn't much, it was just like
a sentence, but they linked to the website.
Well, there was this producer for CBS that
read the article in the New York Times and
then clicked through to my site and sent me an
email and said, "Hey, do you want to come on CBS
This Morning and talk about this piece?" And so
I was like, "Okay, sure." So they flew me to New
York and I did the segment and it was my first
time on TV and so I was all nervous about it,
but I tried to do my best and have a good segment.
And as soon as it got done, I went over to Gayle
King and I said, "Hey, I have this book coming
out in 10 months." So this was 10 months before
Atomic Habits. "I would love to come back and do
a segment about that when the book comes out."
Tim Ferriss: Smart.
James Clear: And she said,
"Sure thing. We'll have you back. Just make
sure that we're your first stop. Don't do any
other interviews on TV shows before us." And so
as soon as I left, I got her email and I sent a
message to her and the publisher and everybody and
I got on the calendar for launch day. And that was
how I got on CBS This Morning for the launch of
Atomic Habits. And that ended up being, I think,
a kind of an important moment for the launch of
the book because it made it feel like a thing.
It wasn't just a guy launching a book, it
was like, oh, this is a bigger event. And
I don't know how many books that segment
sold. I've tried to calculate it. Probably
more than a thousand, probably less than
10,000. Probably somewhere in that range.
But as soon as the segment got over, they put
that clip on YouTube and then two hours later
we took the YouTube clip and emailed it out to
my audience and that was the launch email for
the book that day was like, "Here's my segment on
CBS This Morning. The book is out." And so what
I'm getting at is that work of writing that
article about the physics of productivity,
that work continued to work for me in really
big ways three or five or six years later,
even though the initial article didn't seem
like that big of a deal. And the reason it
worked out is because that was work that
kept working for me once it was done.
So anytime you create an asset that can compound —
a blog post, a podcast episode, even simple stuff
like Twitter posts and Instagram posts are less
likely because they kind of have a short half
life, but even those can be examples of putting
work out there that is still being recorded and
still being stumbled across by people online and
you're creating a large surface area for good
things to kind of break your way If you spend time
doing that. Now I think you can even do better
than that, which is not only can you create assets
that compound and keep working for you, you can do
it in a way where they layer on top of each other.
So I'll spend 20 minutes on a tweet and that seems
kind of an excessive amount of time to spend
writing two sentences. But the time that I put
into that, I'll put it out there and it's its own
little asset, and then maybe if it does well, I'm
like, hey, we should use that in the newsletter.
And so it goes in the newsletter. And then maybe
it becomes the seed of an idea for a longer
chapter or an article in a book or something,
or it gets added to related ideas that can become
something bigger. And so now that 20 minutes is
actually doing a lot more work than just gaining
a few Twitter followers. And if you can find ways
to layer those little assets on top of each other,
then you get three or five or six years down the
line and you really have dramatic effect. So those
are a couple different ways to try to operate in
a high leverage way with a really small team.
Tim Ferriss: In the last week, we're recording
this towards the end of December, 2022, Twitter
is one example, has made a number of changes that
have suspended a number of my Twitter accounts.
And there's no explanation provided, no particular
bad behavior that I or my team can identify,
but suspended nonetheless. And then they get
reinstated and then two days later they'll get
suspended again. Can't figure it out. But what
this means is much when, say, Facebook started,
I don't want to say requiring, highly encouraging
boosting, AKA paying for promotion of posts
to reach your previously organic audience,
people's business models and audience size started
to effectively disintegrate. And having email is
so, so valuable, which is why I'm also spending
some time on this and it's important to me. So
that's just a background, setting the table so
that I can ask you when something is going wrong,
aside from reaching out to say your email service
provider and saying, "Hey, is something broken? Is
there a monkey wrench in the works?"
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How would you
go about figuring things out?
James Clear: I like to think about it as there's
internal distribution. So those are the things
that I own. And you really can only own kind of
a few assets. You can own your website, you can
own your email list, you can own your podcast.
And that's kind of roughly about it. And then
the other bucket is external. So this is other
people's platforms that you can have distribution
on, YouTube, TikTok, Twitter, Facebook, et
cetera. And as much as possible, I think the web,
it is very platform centric right now and people
spend a lot of time on those platforms. I don't
want to be on all of them because I don't have
enough time and energy to be good at all of them,
but there are probably a few that are a good
fit for my audience. So Twitter and Instagram
are the two that we've decided to focus on.
Tim Ferriss: No TikTok dances coming soon?
James Clear: No, no TikTok routines yet. If I
figure out how to tie that into habits, we'll see
what comes. So I post on those two platforms and
then I try to build an audience there. But also
you'll notice a lot of the posts that I put up
on there, so Instagram for example, I have a very
weird Instagram account because I don't share any
pictures of myself. I'm not really interested in
me as an individual being out there, but it's all
about the ideas. And so it's just a bunch of text,
but on many of them, at the bottom of the image
or in the caption, it'll say, here's a quote.
And then at the bottom it'll say, get more ideas
like this, sign up for 3-2-1 and then it'll have
a link to the newsletter. And so the idea is to
subtly be encouraging people to go off platform
and join one of the assets or one of the pieces of
audience that I do own, one of the internal ones
like the website or the newsletter or whatever.
And so I try to get those things to work together
and cross link between the two, and then they can
start to build each other. And I do it the other
way as well, like when I send out a newsletter,
sometimes if the ideas are short enough and they
would make a good tweet, I'll include a little
link under each idea, it'll just say, click to
tweet. And so now the newsletter is driving action
on Twitter. And so it all kind of like you create
this little spider web, this kind of ecosystem
where everything is kind of driving each other and
it all kind of grows together. But the
ultimate idea is to try to point back the
external platforms to the distribution
sources that you do own so that you're
not beholden to any particular one when they
decide to change their strategy or approach,
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Which is specifically why
a whole bunch of stuff is getting banned or
shadow banned right now on Twitter. And
so the best theory I could come up with,
and I can't get this verified or denied, is that
because some of these accounts which were created
for a new podcast that came out have legitimate
contact, but they all link out to Apple Podcasts.
That's the only plausible explanation that we
can come up with for why they have been locked
and they keep getting unlocked. So I don't want
to make anybody seem like the bad guy here, but
it highlights the fragility of having something
that is entirely dependent on a platform that you
don't own. And also if you were to read your terms
of service, you're probably giving all of that
content to the platform as well on some level.
And I recall chatting with this guy,
this is many years ago, before the organic
reach was throttled a lot on Facebook,
chatting with a guy who had a multi-million
dollar business built on a few Facebook pages
and massively successful. And I asked him what it
felt like to run those businesses. And he said,
"I feel like I have the most profitable
McDonald's in the world built on top of an
active volcano." It could go away at any minute,
and I don't want to live with that anxiety also.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And just to add a
few things just to going to feather them
in with your comments. One is it's very
important to adapt. I would add something to
that, which is it's very important to adapt,
but I think it's really critical to have a good
explanation for how you are adapting and not to
discard for the sake of discarding. And just as an
example, to give people a window into my thinking,
Reddit and some of these other platforms still can
drive a lot of traffic, but they're not sexy and
people have started to neglect them. So there's
far less competition on some of these older,
let's just call it platforms that are actually
still innovating quite well in the case of Reddit.
So I've thought about revisiting some
of the vintage powerhouses because
there's been such a mass migration to particularly
short form video. It just seems like a bloodbath.
And I would also say, something I think you've
done very well is set constraints on what you
will or will not do, say on social platforms.
Because one of the risks of adapting is that you
become a slave to the audience in such a way that
you morph into this funhouse mirror caricature of
yourself. And I've seen this happen to a lot of
people where they put out 10 posts and the most
extreme of those gets the most engagement or
feedback or positive likes, et cetera, and so
they then put out five more like that, the most
extreme gets the best response. And a year later,
not only has their social feed become like
the craziest infomercial-pitchman-yelling
circus, but this is the greater risk is that
they in real life have started to become the
mask that they've created for themselves.
This is a very real risk. So setting up the
constraints on what you will or will not do in
advance before you get on that playing field,
I think is really, really, at least for
me, very, very important. How do you think
about that? Or have you thought about that?
James Clear: Well, this connects to one of
the core ideas in Atomic Habits, which is your
habits are how you embody a particular identity.
So the aspects, the behaviors that you perform
each day are reinforcing or shaping the story
that you have about yourself. I think it's
important to ask yourself: who is the type
of person I wish to become? What's the type of
identity I want to be reinforcing? And your habits
are not the only things that influence that in
life. Every experience is part of who you are,
but by virtue of the fact that they get repeated
again and again, they have an outsized influence
on your story. And so the phrase I like to keep
in mind is: every action you take is a vote for
the type of person you wish to become.
Tim Ferriss: That's a great line.
James Clear: And so as you show up each day and
make another YouTube video or do another TikTok
video, you're casting a vote for being that kind
of person. And if you let the algorithm run it,
if you let yourself kind of fall into this, as you
said, mask that you're wearing for the audience,
pretty soon you actually are casting enough
votes that the bulk of the evidence starts
to support that part of your identity.
You start to become that kind of person.
And this is why I come back to some of those
questions that we were talking about earlier like
what am I optimizing for? Or how do I want to
spend my days? Because you've got to start there
and set the positive constraints for yourself.
Who's the type person I wish to become? What kind
of lifestyle am I trying to create for myself? And
then within that constraint, how can I have the
biggest audience? Or how can I make the most
money? Or how can I make the biggest impact?
But I think that's a way of trying to anchor
yourself and not lose yourself and let the
algorithm kind of run the show. So I think your
habits and your identity are very connected and
the actions that you take shape or support,
they provide evidence for the type of person
that you are. And so it's worth asking yourself,
what are my actions moving me closer to? And you
want to make sure that you're on a good path.
Tim Ferriss: May I read something from your
fantastic website? So this is on identity-based
habits. I want to highlight this and add it
to what you just said because I think it's
critically important. And feel free to revise
any of this. And you can't believe everything
you read on the internet too, so who knows.
James Clear: Even if it comes from my own website.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think the CCP has infiltrated
your website or anything like that.
So let me just give this a read.
"The key to building lasting habits is focusing
on creating a new identity first." That's the
sentence I'd love to get your take on. "Your
current behaviors are simply a reflection of
your current identity. What you do now is a mirror
image of the type of person you believe that you
are (either consciously or subconsciously).
To change your behavior for good, you need to
start believing new things about yourself.
You need to build identity-based habits."
Would you like to add anything to that? The
creating a new identity first is I think the
piece that is of greatest interest to me.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: How would somebody
go about doing that? Let's say
they're listening to this, they're
just moving into the new year.
James, please tell me how do I do this?
James Clear: It's kind of a two-step process.
Decide the type of person you want to be, and
then you prove it to yourself with small wins.
And the more small wins, the
more small habits that you
perform, the more votes that you cast for that
identity, the more you build up evidence of being
that kind of person. And eventually you start
to take pride in that aspect of your identity.
And man, once we start to take pride in a part
of our story, it's much easier to stick with
those habits. If you take pride in the size of
your biceps, you'll never skip arm day at the
gym. If you take pride in how your hair looks,
you have this long haircare routine, all these
haircare habits, and you do them every day.
Tim Ferriss: I was going to say, might be past
that point for you and I, my friend.
James Clear: I think you and
I have lost that battle.
Tim Ferriss: Unless you're
talking about chest hair.
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: James, may I jump in for one second?
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: What is a good way to phrase that? So
if someone wants to have, not a mission statement,
but some type of statement for this
is the type of person I want to be.
James Clear: I think it's the type of person who
blank for example. "I'm the type of person who
doesn't miss workouts," or "I'm the type of person
who shows up on time," or "I'm the type of person
who finishes what they start." Whatever aspect
of your identity that you're trying to reinforce,
that's kind of the story. You can also phrase it
as a question. So for example, rather than saying,
"I'm the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts," you could have this question
that's related to the identity you want to build,
and you kind of carry it around with you all day.
And in this example, maybe the question is, "What
would a healthy person do?" And so you're just
kind of walking around all day asking yourself,
"What should I get for lunch? Well, what would a
healthy person do?" Or, "Should I take an Uber,
or should I walk to the next meeting? Well,
what would a healthy person do?" And you just
kind of go around your day and try to make
decisions that you feel support that identity.
But I think you start with "Who is the type of
person I wish to become?" So let's say I'm the
type of person who doesn't miss workouts. And
then the second step is prove it to yourself with
small wins. So which small actions, what little
habits cast votes for being the kind of person who
doesn't miss workouts? Well, maybe one thing is,
rather than doing a 45-minute workout when I only
have 10 minutes, I reduce the scope and stick to
the schedule and I do a couple sprints, or I do
five sets of pushups or whatever it is. And so
you find ways to reinforce your desired identity,
even if it's small, especially in the beginning.
Because if you can show up consistently, if
you kind of master the art of showing up and
performing these small habits, you build up
this sense of momentum, you kind of start to
reinforce and shape that new identity and
the more evidence that you have for it,
at some point you kind of cross this invisible
threshold where you're like, "Oh, I guess I am
that kind of person." If you go out and shoot a
basketball for five minutes, you don't think, "Oh,
I'm a basketball player." But if you do it every
day for six months or a year or two years, at some
point you cross this invisible line. You're like,
"I guess playing basketball is kind of part of who
I am." So I think you're trying to accumulate
actions that support your desired identity.
Tim Ferriss: So let's do a case study and we're
going to take a look at, this is purely selfish,
at email because you've been very methodical and
executed very well with email. I also have the
5-Bullet Friday, which has been going for, God,
I have not missed a week in God knows how many
years. It's been a long time. It's pretty wild.
It serves as sort of a diary for me too. I don't
know if this is true for you, but looking back
at these editions, it is actually very fun for
me because I get to see, "Oh, three-and-a-half
years ago. Oh, yeah. That week. Yeah. Oh, wow."
James Clear: "Look at how
dumb past Tim was. Present
Tim is so much smarter. I've learned so much."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God, yes. A boy can dream, a boy
can dream. So let's say one of my resolutions,
and this is going to be a bit of a force fit,
but not necessarily so.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: I am someone who prioritizes email
above all the other platforms and grows it
consistently. And you may have some familiarity
with my newsletter and how we do things, and I
know you and have had some exchanges before.
James Clear: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: What might be some small
wins or just changes that you would make,
things you would add, try, test, anything at all?
James Clear: Well, when I look at, so I was
browsing your website a little
bit before this conversation,
and I kind of feel like the main difference, also,
first of all, I just need to say, you already have
an enormous email list. So to do some sort of
intervention on somebody who's got millions
of subscribers is kind of a ridiculous premise to
start with. But I'll take the question seriously.
Tim Ferriss: No, no. I want to give credit
where credit is due. I think you have more,
I think that your prioritizing is
better reflected in your actions and
decisions with respect to email than in my case.
James Clear: It's interesting you say that. That
was what I was about to say is I feel like the
only difference, the only primary difference is
you emphasize the podcast as your number one,
and I emphasize email as my number one. And
something has to lead the day. Now of course,
this does not mean that's a bad decision by you,
right? The podcast is enormous and it probably
is the more important thing for your business,
but each person needs to decide what that is. In
my case, if you go to my website, it's very clear,
if something is going to be the primary call
to action on the homepage, it's the email list,
not the podcast or whatever. So that's
just a question that you need to have is:
are we willing to emphasize this more? And if
not, then that's a positive constraint you're
setting and you can decide, okay, given
that email's going to be number two to
the podcast, how could we grow it more?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you've raised such a
simple idea for me. Right now, if you look at the
homepage, it's podcast on the top, on the banner,
and then you have the email sign up, which
is sort of right below that to the right.
James Clear: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: And it could be as simple as like,
all right, well look, this doesn't have to be a
forever decision. Let's just swap, swap those two.
James Clear: Try it out.
Tim Ferriss: For a period of time,
make the top, the whole thing is email.
James Clear: Everybody's biased to how
their story played out. So I'm biased to say
email's the most important, but my stance on
it is make the banner on your homepage the
email list, and then you can email all the
podcast episodes out to these people. It doesn't—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, email, every time I think about
it sensibly, email is the most important because
you can share the podcast much more easily via
email than you can share the newsletter via
podcast, because to share email via podcast
requires task switching almost, I don't want
to say always, but probably 90 percent of the
time if I had to just pull a number out of
my ass, people are listening to a podcast
is a secondary activity. Very different beast
than someone who sits down, opens an email and
clicks on links. They're opening an email
explicitly in the case of 5-Bullet Friday,
and perhaps also in the case of your email
to find things to learn and investigate.
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right? It's an explicit —
James Clear: Well, this is kind of what you're
getting at, but email is in a position where it's,
both of the assets are very flexible. You can
talk about whatever you want on a podcast and
you can write about whatever you want in an
email. But email has the advantage of having
links that you can click on right away. And so it
can be immediately acted upon. Whereas as you've
mentioned, often people are listening to a podcast
while they're on a run or making dinner or in a
car, and they're not in a position to click on
a link right then. And so even if you tell them,
give them a great URL to go to, just the
conversion rate's not going to be nearly
as high because people are busy and then by the
time they get home they don't remember to do it.
So anyway, for all of those reasons, I like
email more, and honestly, I kind of feel like
there are really only two things that came to
mind. The first is, are you going to emphasize
it more in the web design? So put it above the
banner at the top of the page or above the fold.
And then the second thing is how are you
cross-pollinating between your different assets?
So I mentioned Instagram for me. So that's like of
the top five ways that we drive email subscribers,
Instagram is one of them. And the reason is
because a lot of the posts have links at the
bottom that encourage people to sign up for 3-2-1
or they mention the newsletter in the caption
or a story that we post will have an actual
link in it that you can click to the sign
up on the page. And so are you using your
other assets like Instagram or Twitter or
the podcast to drive email subscribers?
Example for the podcast would be,
I know for previous episodes, I don't know if
you do this for every episode, but sometimes
you'll mention 5-Bullet Friday at the end. What
if we mentioned it at the beginning of the show
rather than the end of the show? More people are
going to be listening in the first minute than
are going to be listening in the 120th minute. So
it's really just about using the other assets to
cross-pollinate and to do it at strategic points
that are high leverage. I would rather make fewer
asks, but to do it at the exact right moment
than to sprinkle calls to action everywhere.
So those are the two things to keep in mind.
Tim Ferriss: I want to share one of your
questions, if that's okay. This is from your
newsletter. Someone compiled your questions over
two years and put them in a blog post. And one of
them, let's see. I have many highlighted, this is
one that related to my prioritization of email.
And as you pointed out, focusing on the podcast,
the placement of the mention of 5-Bullet Friday
being at the end as opposed to the beginning.
And it is, if someone could only see my actions
and not hear my words, what would they say are my
priorities? That's a good one. It's a good one.
Yeah, don't tell me what's important. Just show
me your calendar, pal. Yeah. Okay. There we go.
James Clear: We all have the stories that we
tell ourselves. Like it's very easy for us to
justify internally, but if you're just looking
at how you're acting, what are you actually
emphasizing? I think we all have felt that pain
at various times, which I should say, these aren't
just questions I come up with for the readers.
These are all things I need to ask myself. Pretty
much everything I write is intended to help me
get back to center or to course correct.
Tim Ferriss: And also to reinforce something you
just said, the more success you have, even if it's
a small amount, although I do think it tends to go
somewhat exponential at some point. There
may be exceptions to this, but among my
friends and peer group, whatever that might mean,
uniformly I have seen the more success you have,
whether it's a base hit or a double or a home run
or 10 home runs, the harder it becomes to focus
for a lot of people. Because in the beginning
stages of your career or maybe mid stages,
you're choosing between unattractive options
and maybe one or two attractive options.
James Clear: You're trying to generate
attractive options, they're like not —
Tim Ferriss: You trying to generate.
James Clear: You try to create them or find them.
Tim Ferriss: You're trying to generate attractive
options. Exactly. Once you go from having one
attractive option to two attractive options on
your menu, things really change dramatically.
And then when that goes to 10 things and then it
goes to 10 interesting people with 10 interesting
things, it gets harder. And I'm not saying
this to ask my audience to cry a river for me,
I don't expect that, woe is me. These are quality
problems. But you really want to sharpen the acts
of asking these types of questions and
building these systems before you have
your first one or two base hits. Because
if you try to sharpen the ax when you are
feeling as though you are just up to your neck in
water kind of floating down the rapids, it's going
to be very, very hard. So, I would just say —
James Clear: Well, success generates not only
opportunities, but also distractions. And so
in a sense, success almost completes itself.
Tim Ferriss: Sometimes the same thing.
James Clear: It's like,
you get good at something and so then that brings
new opportunities your way. Some of them are novel
or interesting or different. And so you do those
and then you turn around six months later and you
don't have any time to do the thing that made you
successful in the first place. So yeah, you've
got to be careful about what you say yes to.
Tim Ferriss: So I'd like to ask you about two
goals / habits / behavioral modifications that
are of interest to me personally, and also I would
imagine of interest to other people listening.
And I'm curious because you've had 10 million
copies sold, you've interacted with or certainly
observed a lot of your readers, people who have
tested different things from the book. Let's
start with, well, the two that come to mind,
and I've actually, I'm good at the second, but the
two are, cutting back on caffeine and meditating.
So the meditating is an addition. The cutting back
on caffeine, a lot of people would think of as a
subtraction. I would love to hear any thoughts
you might have on cutting back on caffeine.
James Clear: Sure. So if you want to
break a bad habit, there are three
potential paths you could take. So the first is
you can eliminate it entirely. So elimination.
Second option is you can reduce it. So you could
curtail it to the desired degree. I don't want to
never drink caffeine, I just want to drink less of
it. And the third option is you could substitute
it, you could replace it with a different habit.
And of those three, oftentimes replacing it
is actually the more effective option. So for
example, if you get your caffeine from drinking
Coke or soda or something like that, then maybe
you find out, hey, you know something I really
love from this experience is I actually just like
drinking a carbonated beverage. And so it's the
carbonation that I like. And maybe if I substitute
it with sparkling water or something like that,
I still get the carbonation sensation, but I don't
have the caffeine associated with it anymore.
And so that's a way of substituting for that
behavior. And you still get something that the
experience provides. This is actually kind of an
important just larger picture, big picture thing
about habits, which is every habit that you have,
we build habits to solve the repeated problems
that we face in life. And I'm using problems in a
very general sense here. Let's say that you come
home from work and you feel tired and exhausted
from a long day. Well, in a sense, coming home
from work at 6:00 p.m. and feeling tired is a
problem. And especially if you experience it
repeatedly, you've got to come up with some kind
of solution for that. And generally speaking,
we just try things out in life. And so you can
imagine one person solves the problem of feeling
exhausted by scrolling Instagram mindlessly
for 30 minutes. And another person solves
that problem by playing video games for an hour.
And a third person solves it by going for a run
for 20 minutes. And those are all solutions to the
same kind of underlying problem, but some of them
are more healthy or more productive or service
better than others. And what do you think the
odds are that the solutions you've come up with to
the repeated problems in your life are the optimal
one? It's just so unlikely that whatever you
happen to have stumbled into throughout life is
the perfect way or the best habit that serves you
most. So I think what I'm trying to get out there
is maybe take a little bit of the pressure off
yourself, and don't worry about judging yourself
so much. You're just trying to solve the repeated
problems that you face. But once you realize that
it's unlikely that your current solutions
are the optimal solutions, well now maybe
we can step outside and above ourselves and look
down and try to come up with a better solution.
So rather than drinking a Coke to get the
carbonation, we can drink sparkling water.
So that's one example for the substitution. If
we want to take the other path of reduction,
something I've noticed about myself is if I get a
six pack of beer and I put it in the front of the
fridge, like in the door, or on a shelf that's
like right at eye level, I'll drink one every
night just because it's there. But if I take it
and put it on the lowest shelf in the fridge,
and it's kind of all the way back in the corner,
I can't really see it unless I'm bending down.
It'll sit there for two weeks or three
weeks. And so I'm like, did I want it or
not? If it was obvious, then I grab one but
if it wasn't, then I avoid it. And I think
that's a simple question to ask yourself.
Where do I get my caffeine? Is it coffee,
is it soda? And is that really obvious? Is it like
the coffee sitting right out on the counter? Is
the soda the first thing I see at eye level when
I open the fridge? And how can I make it less
obvious? In Atomic Habits, there are kind of what
I call the four laws of behavior change. And it's
just this big picture view of how to build a good
habit. And so if you want to build a good habit,
you want to make your habits obvious, attractive,
easy, and satisfying. And if you want to break a
bad habit, you just do the opposite of those
four. So you want to make it invisible,
make it unattractive, make it difficult,
and make it unsatisfying. And so I think,
how can you make coffee or soda invisible?
How can you make it difficult to drink? Keep
it outside of the house, et cetera. So there are
a variety of strategies you could use here. Let's
say you live with a family and other people are
going to want to drink it, but you don't want to.
Well, there's this little kind of diabolical
Tupperware container called the Kitchen Safe,
and it has a lockbox code on the top of it. And
so you could give the other family members the
lockbox code, but then they don't give it to you
and you just put the soda inside of that and so it
stays in that Tupperware and you can't access it.
So finding ways to increase friction or to make it
difficult or to make it less obvious,
those are all ways to potentially curtail
the caffeine habit.
Tim Ferriss: The
locking Tupperware, what is it called again?
James Clear: It's called the Kitchen Safe.
Tim Ferriss: The Kitchen Safe.
There are a few variations of this,
and I know a number of families who use them
for phones. So they will have mealtime or
evening time or whenever it is, and they'll
put the phones in the safe and that's where
they sit until the phone free time has expired.
James Clear: I've had readers use it for late
night snacking. The chips go in at 7:00 p.m.
or they just stay in that Tupperware. And it's
set to lock from 7:00 p.m. to 7:00 a.m. and
so they just can't get to it late at night.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just imagining myself, so I'll
give you a confession. So I love brownies and two
days ago for the first time, made brownies and
spiced cider, was a whole Christmas celebration
thing, even though it's not Christmas yet. And
I ate all the brownies last night. So I'm not
proud of this. I'm not beating myself up about it
because I'm going to, I'm working out, it's fine.
It's not a big deal. But I'm just imagining if I
put the brownies into this locking container and
do you know what a bear bin is? There are these
bear contraptions that you use for camping. I'm
just imagining being like swatting this safe
around, smashing it on the ground, trying to
get the brownies out. Anyway, that's more for my
own gratification folks. So thanks for listening.
Let's talk about positive. And you already
alluded to the four principles or laws or
ingredients. But meditating, I think for
a lot of folks, meditating is in the air.
They've heard about it on this podcast. "I know I
should do it, I just don't. By the time I have my
coffee and do this and make the sandwiches for
the kids, it's too late." How would you suggest
people approach, say meditating in the morning?
James Clear: So couple things to think about
here. So again, let me just run through the four
laws real quick just as a primer for this answer.
So if you want to build a good habit, roughly
speaking, there are four things that you can do.
You want to make it obvious, you want to make it
attractive, you want to make it easy and you want
to make it satisfying. So obvious, attractive,
easy, satisfying. Now if you're sitting there
and you're thinking, how can I get myself to
meditate more? You can just turn those into
questions and you can say, how can I make the
behavior more obvious? How can I make it more
attractive? How can I make it easier? How can
I make it more satisfying? And you'll start to
notice different things that you could do. So for
example, how can I make meditation more obvious?
Well, do you have a clear space where you're going
to do this? Maybe you need a meditation pillow and
it's in the corner of your bedroom or it's in the
corner of some other room that is the dedicated
meditation space. And this is exactly where it
happens. So it's obvious where the behavior's
going to occur. Make it attractive. There are
many different types of meditation and there
are a lot of ways to get into it. And this is
true for any habit, by the way. For some reason,
I think we often choose habits that we feel
like we should do, but it's not necessarily
the one that we want to do individually. And
there may not necessarily be a thousand ways
to do everything in life, but there's almost
always more than one way. And you should choose
the version that you're most genuinely excited
about. That is most appealing and interesting to
you. Because if you're genuinely interested in it,
there's going to be all kinds of ways to improve.
You'll find all sorts of things that you could
refine or make it better. But if you're not
actually interested, if you're not genuinely
engaged in the task, even the obvious stuff is
going to feel like a hassle. It is going to feel
like a chore even if it's straightforward. So
do you want a guided meditation? Maybe it'd
be nice to have somebody walk you through it.
Or do you want to find a meditation that has
lovely music associated with it? Do you not
want anything? Do you just want silence? And
you want to be able to hear yourself think
for a minute or listen to your own breath for
five minutes? And that's kind of the objective.
But what sounds most attractive and appealing
to you? Try to find a version of the habit that
you're actually interested in. This actually,
I think connects to the timing piece that you
were talking about, Tim, which is yeah, in the
morning is a great time for a lot of people,
but if you have young kids and your four-year-old
is running around and you're trying to figure out
how to get pants on them and you need to make
breakfast, that's probably not a good time to
do it. So find a time and a space where that
habit can live, where it's attractive and
you're not just going to end up frustrated
because you're trying to swim upstream.
Make it easy. So rather than doing 15 or 20
minutes or 30 minutes of meditation, which hey,
that sounds great because your favorite guru
does it. But listen, why not just do 60 seconds?
Because if you can master the art of showing up,
if you can just do it for a minute and actually
stick to that day in and day out, then you're
starting to build the habit and now you have
something, you've like gained a foothold and you
can advance the next level. One of the things I
recommend in the book is called the two-minute
rule. And it says, just take whatever habit
you're trying to build and you scale it down to
something that takes two minutes or less to do.
So read 30 books a year becomes read one page
or meditate five days a week for 30 minutes,
becomes meditate for 60 seconds and you're just
trying to master the art of showing up. A habit
must be established before it can be improved.
It's got to become the standard before you worry
about optimizing it into some perfect thing.
So make it easy to do. Make it easy to show up.
And then the final thing is make it satisfying.
Now, if you've done those first three steps well,
it's obvious, it's an attractive version of it.
It's pretty easy to do. You're probably going to
feel pretty good about yourself because you're at
the end of the meditation session now. So that'll
probably be pretty satisfying. But you can layer
on some additional benefit. Maybe you get to have
your favorite type of coffee or your favorite
drink after that, or maybe you get to have
a bubble bath or a walk in the woods or whatever
sounds motivating to you. So find some way to
add some additional positive emotions to the
experience because if you feel good about it,
you're going to want to repeat it. And this is
something that in Atomic Habits, I call it the
cardinal rule of behavior change, which is
behaviors that get rewarded, get repeated,
and behaviors that get punished, get avoided.
And it's so basic, it's so obvious. But all
humans want to feel good. We all want to
have positive emotions, to be supported,
to be loved, to be rewarded, to have something
that feels good. And so how can you get that
feeling and associate it with your habits?
That's kind of the core idea. And ultimately,
this connects back to what we talked about with
identity, which is the perfect version is when
you perform a habit and you feel good because it's
reinforcing your desired identity. I'm the type of
person who wants to meditate each day, or I'm
the type of person who doesn't miss meditation
sessions. And then even if it's only 60 seconds,
you can feel good about doing it because it's
reinforcing your desired identity. So that's kind
of a quick case study on how to apply the ideas.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. And as you're
speaking, I'm thinking about all these other
questions and how you could phrase the, I'm the
type of person who looks forward to meditating.
How do you make that a true statement? And it
actually brought me back to San Francisco many,
many, many years ago before I took my first
meditation training and so on and so forth.
I began, I hadn't thought about this in like
a decade at least. I began with listening to,
I think it was, "We're going to party
like it's 1999" by Prince, one song.
James Clear: Nice.
Tim Ferriss: And in the
morning I would just sit down, lean against the
wall, getting good posture and just breathe deeply
while listening to Prince for one song. That was
it. And it made a difference. It made a difference
because as you said, I've never thought of it in
these terms, but I became accustomed to showing up
and simply having, however small it
might have been, and it was small,
a tiny slot in my mental calendar, which was,
when I wake up, I'm going to sit down and do
this thing. And then when I did Transcendental
Meditation training later, and I experimented
with many different forms of meditation
since, going from three minutes to 20 minutes
was a dilation of the amount of time required,
but it wasn't introducing an entirely new
species of calendar slot. It was already there.
James Clear: Once you've mastered the art of
showing up, scaling it up, increasing the scope is
much easier once you're already the kind of person
who's doing it every day. Yeah, those are good
examples. I think actually maybe, I don't know if
it's your question, Tim, I feel like I've heard
you say it before, but this idea of, what would
this look like if it was easy? Or, what would
it look like to be the kind of person who looks
forward to writing or looks forward to meditating
or looks forward to working out? That's a question
worth taking seriously, because you can usually
design the habit to feel like, hey, this isn't a
chore. This is something, this is how I want to
be spending my days. And that's really where you
want to get to because for a habit to last, it's
got to be part of your normal lifestyle. It has to
be something that, like you want to show up and
do this each day. And so you're trying to find
the version of it that benefits you the most.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. "What would this look like,
or what might this look like if it were easy?"
is a question I ask myself all the time. And
part of the reason for that is that I've,
for most of my life, prided myself on having
high pain tolerance, being able to do the hard
things and the service of the long term. And
when you're starting out, like you said, kind
of clawing your way to any good opportunity or
any open window when you're just kind of slipping
back on the mud slope of establishing any type of,
James Clear: Yeah. You're opening windows that
are closed. People are like, that was locked.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. Like clawing like a raccoon
at the window trying to figure out the lock. And
at least for me, I think I began to associate
results with grinding or some degree of effort.
And so the association would be, if my effort
isn't above a certain threshold, I am not
doing the thing that will produce an optimal
result, but past a certain point that can be a
false filter, if that makes any sense. So I
ask myself that constantly. If I'm recording a
podcast, I've thought, just to give an example,
I haven't done this yet, but I've thought,
you know what? The technology is good enough. Why
do I do podcasts? At least as it stands right now
in a static position. Why not figure out, get the
best headset available, figure out connectivity,
and go for a walk, figure out a way to record a
podcast while I'm walking. I would check off a
number of these laws that you mentioned.
James Clear: Microphone in one hand,
Starlink dish in the other. You're just
going to be like the ultimate version of
the guys sifting for gold on the beach.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, that'd be amazing.
I just put the Starlink on the back of
my head, mount it on top of the headset.
Let's use Atomic Habits as the case study.
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: How would you deconstruct
Atomic Habits both in its writing,
but then also its launch, right? Because those are
intertwined in what made it successful. What were
the things that really seemed to be the Archimedes
levers for producing, to the extent that you can,
right? You're on one side of the tennis net.
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So any examples?
James Clear: This will probably
be a long answer because there's a lot to talk
about. So let's break it into two categories,
writing and marketing. And also the truth
is, the honest answer might be like,
I don't know, I got lucky. Maybe that's
the truth. But I suspect that there are
things, a lot of things you can do to influence
the outcome. And so I'll walk you through what
I tried to do. So on the writing side, I think
you have to operate with this assumption of like,
let me create more value than I'm going to
capture. You try to produce a hit. The ultimate
thing that drives book sales is creating something
that is actually genuinely valuable to people. And
it has to be so good that people will talk about
it. Word of mouth, you know, Atomic Habits has
sold over 10 million copies at this point.
We could argue, I'd be interested to know
what you think the estimate is, Tim, but there's
some number of copies that you could sell just by
having an audience and a good marketing plan
and sheer force of will and putting a lot of
effort in. Maybe it's 25,000, maybe it's
a hundred thousand, I don't know. At some
point there's some number where you can't get
beyond that, even if you have a large audience
just by the marketing energy. It has to be word
of mouth. And I think certainly once you're in the
millions or tens of millions of copies, the only
way a book grows that much is people recommend it.
And I like Seth Godin's measure for this, which
is, he says, "If you want word of mouth, you have
to create something remarkable." And that means
that it's worthy of remark, that it's worthy of
talking about. And so you have to start with that.
So the three things that I always focus on are,
am I writing something that's timeless?
So if it's timeless and evergreen,
then you have a longer period where it could
become a hit. If it's something that's just
really relevant to the current moment, two years
from now, you've kind of passed your window for
it taking off. But if it's genuinely timeless —
Tim Ferriss: Like the blog post you wrote that
got to the producers for television.
James Clear: Yes, right, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Similar example.
James Clear: Right.
Am I writing something that's pretty universal?
So that's another kind of filter for me.
Everybody has habits. Everybody's trying to
build good habits or break bad ones, even if
they're not thinking about it carefully, it's
just kind of part of life. And so not everybody
in the world's going to buy the book, but pretty
much anybody can look at the cover and be like,
yeah, I get why that would be useful. That's
a thing that most people are going to want.
So timeless, is it universal? And then I feel
like you have to pick something that fascinates
you because if you're genuinely interested
in it, that comes through in the writing.
I think Morgan Housel has some kind of line
where it's like, "Writing for yourself is
fun and it shows. Writing for other people is
work and it shows." And people have a good BS
meter for that. And you need to pick in your,
Tim Ferriss: Quick side sell for Morgan, The
Psychology of Money. The title may seem generic.
The book is outstanding. I really enjoyed it.
James Clear: Yeah. Yeah, he's fantastic. Okay. So
that's kind of like my write something timeless,
write something universal, write something that
fascinates you and do all that with the intention
of creating something genuinely remarkable or that
creates value for people. Those things sound good.
I think it's worth asking like, what does it
look like in practice to actually do that? So
let me just give you some examples.
Tim Ferriss: And I'm just going to
keep interrupting because I've had too much
caffeine. I'm going to blame it on the caffeine.
I would also love to at some point, so you're
going to give some examples. I would love to
know how you thought about modeling other
books or constructing the format and layout
of your book. Not the visual layout per se.
James Clear: No, I know what you mean.
Tim Ferriss: Structuring the book. Because
I've seen many examples of you deconstructing
sentences, quotes, application
essays. We probably won't get to that,
but when you went to Switzerland, right?
You're very good at modeling. So at some
point I'd love for you to speak to that.
James Clear: Yeah. I think you should
deconstruct the cool things that you see in
life. Like when you come across something that
you really like or that you think is cool, so
in my case, I was writing a book, so how do I
deconstruct bestsellers? What's going on there?
And if you find a single example of something,
it doesn't really tell you anything. But
if you start to find patterns, then that's
probably something to pay attention to. So I
think, actually this is a great segue to some
of these examples I was going to give. So let's
say when I was writing Atomic Habits early on,
I was like, I know what I'm trying to achieve.
I'm trying to write the most comprehensive
and most useful book that's ever been written on
habits. Now I have no idea if I achieved that. And
it's not really for me to decide if we're being
honest, I don't get to choose that it did that.
That's up to the readers to decide is that a
mark that you hit or not? But I think that has
to be the target. You've got to start there.
Otherwise, you're never just going to stumble
into that outcome. So you have to try
to intend to create something great.
So how do we do that? I looked at a bunch of
books, not just about habits, but also other
bestsellers. One of the first things I did was
I went to the table of contents for all those
books. And then I was like, how are these books
arranged? And what you'll find is that a lot of
bestselling books, they break things into thirds
or it doesn't always have to be thirds, but they
have a clear structure that the book goes through
so that you can look at the table of contents. And
even though you don't know what's in the chapters,
you know exactly where you're headed as a reader.
What people don't want is they don't want to open
up a book and feel lost, feel like, "I have no
idea where this guy's going to go with this." And
it kind of feels like they're wasting their time.
A couple examples. You could do, and I thought
about these, but I didn't actually use these for
Atomic Habits. I could've had a table of contents
that was like "Habits of the Past," "Habits of the
Present," "Habits of the Future." You know pretty
clearly where that book's going to go, if you see
those categories in the table of contents. Or
Power of Habit is another example. If you look
at the table of contents there, I think he does
"Habits of Individuals," "Habits of Businesses,"
and then "Habits of Societies." So it's like
individuals, organizations, societies, and you
can see how he's kind of moving up the hierarchy
as you go through the book. Another one that I
looked at, I can't remember which one of Cal
Newport's books it was, but it was either Deep
Work or something like that. But he had a section
on, here are the rules that you need to follow and
then there were four rules or six rules, and so
each one of those got their section in the book.
The point is just there needs to be a clear
roadmap for the reader. And if you start
looking through what other bestsellers are
doing, you can start to think about how to
transport that onto your own experience.
Another thing I did was I tried to look at
what is the average chapter length for a lot
of these books. When I signed the book deal,
the publisher and the editors I was working
with, which I love my publishing team by the way,
but they were kind of encouraging me to write
longer chapters, like 6,000 or 8,000 words. And
I was coming at this as a blogger. Most of the
things I wrote were like 2,000 words or 1,500
words. Eventually what I settled on was most of
the chapters were between 2,000 and 3,000 words.
And that felt like the right one, you know?
Tim Ferriss: And just for folks to have a
reference point. I mean one printed page, what
would you say, it's roughly like 350 words?
James Clear: Yeah, I think most of
my chapters were about 10 pages. So
300 words. Yeah, if it's a 3,000 word chapter,
maybe it's 10 or 12 pages, something like that.
So yeah, figuring out the length. I started
to notice other things that novels would do or
books that weren't necessarily non-fiction. The
chapters are really shortened. There's kind of
this momentum that gets into it. It kind of
gets you flipping pages and it's easier to
keep churning through the chapters. And so I
wanted to have that kind of chapter length.
I actually think Atomic Habits is still a
little bit longer than I was hoping. I just
couldn't figure out to compress it more. My
initial manuscript for the book was 700. It
was like 712 pages or something. And the
finished version of the book is like 250.
So I compressed it by 66 percent or whatever.
So it's much smaller than it started out as,
which I think is good because I feel like
a lot of books, especially business books,
they could have been a blog post or a 20-page
paper and they get turned into a 200-page book.
So I wanted to do the opposite.
Tim Ferriss: I fucking hate
that. It's the worst. It's so bad.
James Clear: But I actually think
if you look at books that sell really well, a
lot of the time they're like 180 to 220 pages,
they're actually even a little bit shorter than
what I ended up hitting. So these are all examples
of deconstructing bestsellers on what's going
on. Probably the most important place to do
this is with titles. So I have a spreadsheet of
hundreds of titles for books. The way that I did
it was I said, "I'm only going to look at books
that have sold a million copies or more. That's
what I'm trying to achieve. So let me just see
how many books I can find that have done that."
Tim Ferriss: Quick question, tactical
question, did you do that through
access to Nielsen BookScan?
James Clear: I didn't have access
to BookScan because I was just a poor
blogger who was trying to make a book,
so I didn't have access to any of that stuff. But
what I did was I just did tons of Google searches.
Usually what happens is that when an author hits a
million copies or four million or whatever, they —
Tim Ferriss: They'll let you know.
James Clear: Yeah, they let you know. And
so there's all kinds of stuff, or you'll find like
if you just search a title and then copies sold,
there's New York Times articles that
profile an author and they say, "Their
book sold six million copies," or whatever.
So it was just a bunch of legwork like that.
Anyway, I put together that spreadsheet.
Let's say I've got 150 titles or something,
and then I started to look for patterns. So
what format do all these titles follow? I
think I ended up coming up with, they're about
six. I won't be able to remember them all off
the top of my head, but the most common format
is the blank of blank. So The Power of Habit,
The Life-Changing Magic of Tidying Up, The
Power of Now, The Power of Positive Thinking,
The Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck, The blah,
blah, blah. So it's always the blank of blank,
The War of Art. It's a very proven format. The
Psychology of Money, we can just keep going on and
on and on. There are so many examples like that.
Usually what people do is they take their topic,
and that's the second piece, and then they
take some type of descriptor, and that's the
first one. Ideally, you're combining things that
are not usually combined like, The Life-Changing
Magic of Tidying Up. So tidying up is the
topic of the book, but now you're telling
me that it's life-changing. And what you find
is a lot of these bestselling books, they have
some element of contrast in the title. There's
something that's unexpected about it. Another
common format is you just take, and this is —
Tim Ferriss: Subtle Art of Not Giving a Fuck,
right? You don't usually think subtle art.
James Clear: Yeah, the F word is actually
the least subtle thing, right? So there's
this interesting contrast between the two.
Another common format, this is the one that I
use for Atomic Habits, is you take the topic
of your book and then you layer on some
kind of unexpected descriptor before it.
I'll get to Atomic Habits in a second, but
Extreme Ownership by Jocko. The idea is you
take ownership and responsibility for your
life, but you do it in this extreme way. It's
not just a regular idea of taking ownership.
Or Cal Newport, Deep Work. You're doing work,
but it's a special kind of work. It's not the
normal type of thing that you're thinking about.
These are just examples. There are a couple more
patterns that I found. And then ultimately you've
got to decide like, which one makes the most
sense for me? Which one feels like it's the
best fit for my book?
Tim Ferriss:
And which one can you live with forever?
James Clear: Yes. Titles are really tricky
because they need to pass a lot of filters. They
need to cover what the book is actually about.
Like in my case, it needed to actually talk
about habits. I think it's important to have
some element of contrast. In my case, "atomic"
has multiple meanings. It can be tiny or small,
so your habit should be easy to do. It can be the
fundamental unit in a larger system. So like atoms
build into molecules and systems versus goals is
a big part of the book. It can be the source of
immense energy or power. So I think if you combine
all those three meanings, you get the big arc of
the book, which is you make changes that are small
and easy to do, you layer them on top of each
other like units in a larger system, and then you
end up with these powerful or remarkable results
as a byproduct. So for all of those reasons, I
felt like atomic was a great word to describe it.
So It needs to describe what the topic is.
It needs to be interesting and compelling or
a little bit different. Sometimes good habits
are a little bit weird in a sense. Nobody was
really using the phrase "atomic habits"
before the book came out. It wasn't like
a way that you would describe a habit. You might
describe it as small, but you wouldn't describe
it as atomic. And so that allows me to —
Tim Ferriss: Good habits also, if it had
been good habits, just for people out
there, you're going to be competing
with the entire internet for search results.
James Clear: I actually think a lot of titles fall
into this pitfall, which is they use a phrase that
is commonly used and you want a phrase that you
can own in the reader's mind. You don't want to be
competing with all the other things that use the
phrase "good habits." 4-Hour Workweek is a good
example of this. Nobody really used that phrase
before the book. It was a little bit weird in the
sense that it wasn't part of normal conversation,
and that allowed you to own it.
Tim Ferriss: For sure.
James Clear: It also had that element of contrast
where you're like, "Man, I work for 40 hours a
week, you're telling me I can work for four?"
So it's this surprising thing. Another example
that might be like Rich Dad Poor Dad. That book
has this element of contrast between the two.
So it needs to be something that you actually
want, it needs to cover the topic of the book,
it needs to have this element of contrast.
There's a lot of filters for it to pass,
and that's why coming up with good titles is hard.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Let me add one thing too,
because there may be some — I have a lot of
engineers and computer scientists and so on who
listen to this podcast. If you guys are starting
to develop hives, because this sounds like,
"Oh, my god, this is marketing. I hate
marketers. All marketers are liars."
I'd like to emphasize that if you want
anything, I shouldn't say anything,
if you want a book you write to be remarkable,
there are some prerequisites. In other words,
what are the antecedents to something be
being or becoming remarkable? One of them is
it needs to be remembered. People can't remember
the title, it's very hard to remark upon it in any
way that is meaningful. And this also translates
and applies to the table of contents. So in The
4-Hour Workweek I had this DEAL structure and
I thought very, very, very intently about how
to structure the book, but then also how
to label the different structures and I
had multiple options that could have worked.
If you have the book in your hand, almost all
of them could have worked. But if I want someone
to be able to remember apply and also talk about,
which requires recall, the elements in the
book, having something that is an acronym,
DEAL, that is easy to remember was I think
a critical ingredient. To your point, given
how many things are outside of your control, not
sufficient to guarantee in any way that something
will hit the bestseller list, but necessary.
So necessary but not sufficient, I think.
What were some of the critical decisions, or I
suppose critical decisions is most interesting to
me, but it could also be lucky happenings that you
set the conditions for? If that makes any sense.
James Clear: First of all, the launch of
Atomic Habits, I started planning it about
15 months ahead of time. It was like a
15-month process. That doesn't mean it
has to be that long. I think you could still
do an excellent launch in nine months maybe,
but you're going to need a lot of time. Sometimes
I'll hear from authors and they'll be like, "Hey,
my book's coming out in two months, what should I
do?" I still think there are plenty of things to
do, but in a sense you're already a year behind.
It's long process and to take it that seriously —
it's not like an accident when you see a lot of
these books doing that, people are spending a lot
of time on it. So that's the first thing is you
need to take it seriously and give it enough time.
So what do you do with that year? Well, we
didn't really do much different. There's not
many things that I did that you have never heard
of an author doing before, but we did them at a
larger scale than most people would've done.
So let's take podcasts, for example. Doing a
podcast tour for your book is a very popular,
typical thing to do when your book comes out.
We put together a list. So I went through
iTunes and I clicked on every category of shows
that we felt like could be relevant to
the book. So health and fitness, business,
et cetera, and went all the way through. For each
of those categories, I think usually iTunes lists
like a hundred shows or so in each category.
So we went through all the hundred for each of
those categories, and then we identified every
show that was already an interview show. So I
wasn't trying to convince anybody to bring me
on that wasn't already talking to people. Then
put all those shows in a spreadsheet.
I think we ended up with maybe 300. And
then I wrote individual emails to all 300 hosts.
So that takes a long time. Now we had a general
template, but I would customize each one. And
there was a section in each email where I would
say, "Hey, you've had on this previous guest
in this episode, or you talked about this topic
in this episode, I feel like I could provide
something new or expand on that. It seems like
it already went over well with your audience. If
you're interested, I'd love to come on. I'm sure
the show is going to be successful whether
I come on or not, but if you're interested,
let me know and I feel like we could have a
good conversation." And you've got to send 300
of those emails for 100 of them to work out.
And so I wrote the drafts up and then I think
about three to four months before the book came
out, it was about four months, we started sending
them all out and getting interviews scheduled.
I spent a two-month span before the book came
out recording as many as I could. And I ended
up getting about 75 interviews recorded before
launch week. We asked everybody to release
during launch week. Now, not everybody did,
but pretty much everyone at least would either
do that week or one of the weeks before or after.
And this is one of my core principles for the
launch, which is you want a concentrated strike.
You want to have as much energy as possible in
a tight window. The idea, which Tim you know
this better than almost anybody, the idea
is to make it seem bigger than it actually
is. You want to feel like it's everywhere.
And so I had 75 interviews hit during launch week.
I did an additional 25 during the month that the
book came out. So by the time the book was out for
one month, I had a hundred interviews that had hit
within that same month span. So you've got a lot
of action going on there. At this point, by the
time the book came out, my email list was around
400,000-450,000 subscribers, somewhere around
there. So I had my own energy that I was trying
to provide. So we sent a sample chapter, we sent
the first chapter of the book out. I sent a couple
excerpts during launch week. I had that segment
that I did on CBS This Morning on launch day, and
we sent that out. So there were probably four or
five emails that were coming out around that time.
Similar to what you did with 4-Hour Body and so
on, I did a series of bonuses. So if you bought
the book during launch week, I think there was a
private webinar with me where you could ask any
question. If you bought three copies, you got
some extra PDF downloads and a secret chapter.
If you got 10 copies, you got something else.
I think I only had three categories, one copy,
three copies, and 10. I did have one additional
higher tier. It was like, if you buy 500 books
or 1,000 books or something like that, I would
come and give a keynote. And I would not do that
one again because I ended up giving a keynote in
Malaysia and a keynote in Australia just because —
Tim Ferriss: Surprise.
James Clear: Yeah. So
there were some smart people out
there internationally who were like,
"This is a great deal for us." Anyway, but
it was fun. It was all part of the launch.
And so I did the bonuses, I did the emails
to my audience, we did the podcast push,
and all of that action is happening more
or less in the same two-week window,
but definitely in the same one-month window.
So we've got all this kind of energy happening.
We also sent out influencer copies or whatever
you want to call that, advanced copies to people.
I didn't want to send any galleys to anybody.
I only wanted to send a finished copy because
I wanted their experience to be the actual,
finished book. I want it to be as good as
possible. So we waited to send those out.
Tim Ferriss: You compiled
a list of advanced folks.
James Clear: Yes, but my thing, again,
the same way with the podcast, I only wanted to
do it with people who opted in. I'm not trying
to spam people with the book. Again, this takes
a lot of effort. We had to come up with a list
of people who we thought would be a good fit,
and then we sent them all messages and said,
"Hey, I've got this book coming out, would you
be interested? If so, what's the best address to
send it to?" And it was only people —
Tim Ferriss: How did you find those
people? Sorry to be a pain in the ass.
James Clear: No, no, no, no. It's a good question.
Tim Ferriss: Who's a good fit?
James Clear: Yep. The obvious answer,
the one that everybody thinks of is, oh, it's
people with a big audience who are interested in
the topic that I'm writing about. But I actually
think you can do much better than that, which is
we made a list. So again, what are we trying to
do here? We're trying to give the book a push
and help it generate word of mouth. So I think one
thing that you could do is say, which communities
already have a lot of word of mouth? What are the
type of things that people are interested in that
they just can't shut up about? And so I came
up with a list of things, CrossFitters, vegans,
bullet journalers, parenting and
mommy blogs. I came up with a bunch
of categories of people who they love to
talk about their thing. And so I think I
ended up having 15 categories or so.
Tim Ferriss: That's brilliant. James,
can I pause for one second?
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: There's a restaurant here
in Austin called, I think it's El Arroyo,
and they're famous for their signs that they put
outside and they have these really pithy sayings,
and these have become books now, mugs, everything,
because they're so clever. One of them was,
"If someone does CrossFit and is vegan,
which do they talk about first?" Which
I thought was pretty good. So continue.
James Clear: It's a worthwhile question
though. There are things that people get genuinely
excited about and love to talk to other people
that are in that industry about, or interested
in that thing. So let's come up with a list of
those. I think I had 15 or so. And then I went
through those 15 and I started asking, "Okay,
which of these communities is the book a good
fit for? Where do I feel like there's overlap?"
Tim Ferriss: That's so smart. Very smart.
James Clear: So then I came up with a subset, but
I don't remember what it was, but let's say it was
five or something. CrossFitters were one of them,
as an example. And so I think one of the first
sets that we did was we said, "Let's try to find
all the big CrossFitters on Instagram." And then I
think the first batch that we sent out, we did 30
CrossFitters, we did 30 venture capitalists,
and we did 30 parenting and mommy blogs.
Tim Ferriss: Why venture capitalists? If you
don't want me asking. That one seems to stand out.
James Clear: Wait, what did you say?
Tim Ferriss: Why venture capitalists?
That stands out from the others.
James Clear: There was a lot in the
book about growth, getting one percent better each
day, continuous improvement, process and business
habits, building a successful company. I am often
asked to speak at companies or to speak to sales
teams about those types of things. So all of that
focus on systems and continuous improvement. We
felt like it overlapped well with business. And
venture capitalists are seeing lots of businesses,
and they're the kind of modern version of venture
capitalists. A lot of them have public presence
on Twitter or they've got their own podcasts
or whatever. So it was the kind of thing where
we felt like the topic overlapped and they
had an audience that they could talk to.
Tim Ferriss: Let me dig a little bit on this
because I'm fishing, and it may be a fool's
errand, but I can kind of illustrate something
even if it doesn't apply to you. Were you sending
them to the venture capitalists in part because
if you had say endorsement or broadcast in some
fashion to their audiences, maybe it wouldn't
result in a lot of copies sold. But if one of
your income streams is speaking to businesses
and so on, that it could bolster that side?
James Clear: That might be true. That was
definitely not what I was thinking when I
was doing the launch. It might be true, it might
be a good idea, maybe I should have been thinking
about it. But all I was thinking about at the
launch was where are my potential readers hanging
out and how can I get in front of them or make it
known to them that this book exists and they would
probably enjoy it. Again, this all kind of goes
back to this feeling of this concentrated strike
or not wanting to have a lot of energy in a small
window. So we sent out those influencer copies.
What ended up happening is that the CrossFitters
were the best fit. I think part of the reason is
venture capitalists, for example, I don't even
know how many — they all opted in, so I only sent
them to people that said they wanted a copy.
I messaged Sam Hinkie for example, and he was
like, "Yeah, I would love a copy." So then I sent
him one or whatever. So it was that kind of thing.
But they just didn't talk about it as much
or maybe they had a lot on their plate and
they didn't read it right away. Whatever the
reason was, the CrossFitters did best. I think
it was kind of interesting to them. I feel like
if you're a CrossFitter and you have a million
followers on Instagram, you're probably sent
a lot of workout gear, a lot of supplements,
a lot of stuff like that, but you're very
rarely sent a book. And it was like, "Oh,
this is kind of cool. This is a topic that will
help me in my training and I don't usually get
this." And so they opened it up and a lot of them
took a picture and then shared it on Instagram.
We didn't ask for any of that, by the way. We just
asked people who opted in and then we tried to
get them a book that we felt like was a great
fit for what they were already interested in.
What ended up happening is, I've got all these
podcasts sitting, I have the emails going out,
I got the CBS segment, and then 20 of the
top CrossFitters all posted about it on
their story within the same two-week span. Now,
if you're into CrossFit and you follow the top
CrossFitters on Instagram and you see —
Tim Ferriss: That surround sound.
That means everyone is seeing this book.
James Clear: And you're like, "Man, everybody
I know is reading this right now." And that's not
true at all, but it feels like it in your little
universe. And so again, it's like, how can you
make it feel like it's everywhere for that window
of time? And so once we figured out that it worked
well for CrossFitters, then we started saying,
"Okay, let's branch out in fitness." So then we
sent it to a bunch of bodybuilders, a bunch of
power lifters and so on. And it has turned out
that it's been a really great fit for people in
fitness and they love the book and they recommend
it to their clients, and they find it useful for
their own training and so on. And so we had to
try a variety of things for that to work out.
I actually do think it's one that a lot of
venture capitalists like now and recommend,
but it just was a slower burn with them. It
didn't work during the influencer push as much.
Anyway, you get the idea. None of those
strategies are radical or new. Everybody
is familiar with that if you're looking up, how
should I launch a book? But what's different is
we tried to do it all at the same time, and we
tried to do it all at a larger scale than most
people were doing. At first, we only sent
a hundred influencer copies. Over time,
we've sent a thousand. Sorry, what was that?
Tim Ferriss: Well, you're also very surgical
in where you chose to go an inch wide and a
mile deep. Where I think a lot of folks who I
observed launching books, they kind of half-ass
two dozen things.
James Clear: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, that sounds too pejorative
maybe, but they really try to scatter,
sprinkle effort across a ton of different
things. And I've never seen that work well.
If we're trying to quantify it, let's just say
one of your goals is to be on the bestseller list.
That could be the Wall Street Journal, which at
least last I checked, is a truer bestseller list.
It's compiled based on Nielsen BookScan and other
metrics. The New York Times list has sales input,
but it's largely editor's choice list.
James Clear: I think the best one is Amazon,
because the Amazon charts are the
only source that compiles print,
e-book, and audio into a single number.
Now they don't have every book sale,
they're only counting what's on Amazon,
but that's, I don't know, 80 percent,
90 percent of print books. It's probably
95 percent of audiobooks, Audible is,
basically the only way that people listen to
audiobooks. And it's most e-books too, because
Kindle's the way that most people read e-books.
So I think it's probably the truest number of what
books are actually selling best —
Tim Ferriss: It is the truest.
James Clear: — is the most sold list on Amazon.
Tim Ferriss: It is the truest. However,
just like your morning TV show, the New York
Times, just as a specific list, has a mindshare
that these other bestselling list [do] not have.
James Clear: Well, what did we put on the cover
of Atomic Habits? We put, "#1 New York Times
Bestseller." Not number one on the Amazon charts.
Tim Ferriss: Right, exactly.
James Clear: Isn't that interesting? It's the
truest number, but it doesn't have the branding.
Tim Ferriss: So if you want to hit that list, at
least last I checked, depends on the category and
so on. But you really want to have, let's just say
the possibility of selling, again, depending on
your week, and I would suggest people do research
and choose a soft week if you're competing in this
way. That's what I did with 4-Hour Workweek. Just
as a side note. You can study these things. If
you have a cookbook, maybe you shouldn't come out
right before Thanksgiving and Christmas. You're
going to be fighting monsters if you try to do
that. So pick your timing. But if you have to
sell, let's just call it or have a chance of
selling 20,000 copies for two consecutive weeks,
if you could only choose one way to do that,
one medium, podcasts, email, fill in
the blank, which would you choose? Okay.
And then if you had the ability to add on a
second, which would you choose? If you had to
shape your entire launch strategy around
that, then what would you do? I think it's
just a thought exercise that is worth doing
so that you do not succumb to the distraction
and well-meaning advice of many people
who will say, "You have to be on this,
you have to be on this. You must do this, this,
this, this, this." And before you know it,
you're going to have a must-do list of 20
different things, many of which are mutually
exclusive if you're trying to be excellent
in any one of those. Question for you, what
do you think would've happened had you not had
your email list? Or instead of it being 450,000
people at the time and had been 4,500 people?
James Clear: Yeah, I mean, that's a good question.
Obviously, there's no way to know, but it made
an enormous difference. In my personal story,
it's the only reason that the book happened to
begin with because I was just a lowly blogger. I
have no credentials. I don't work for the New York
Times, I don't teach at Harvard. The publishers in
New York would probably tell you, "Oh, we were
looking for a book on habits and we really like
his writing and stuff." But the truth is they
would've never let me in the room if I didn't
have an email list of hundreds of thousands of
people. That's the thing that got me in the door.
So this is one of the things that I love about
writing, which is competence matters more than
credentials. Anybody can write on any topic and
that is a good thing and a bad thing. The bad
thing is that means you need to be careful about
what you read, because people can just make stuff
up and write whatever they want. But the good
part is competence is what matters. You don't need
permission from anybody. What you need is to write
something exceptional. You need to write something
that genuinely makes a difference and is useful
in people's lives. And if you genuinely deliver on
the problem that you're writing about, then you're
in a good position to make a career out of it.
Anyway, that wasn't a direct answer to your
question, but I think the email list was an
enormous important part of it. It got the book
deal to begin with, and it also really moved
the needle on book sales during launch week. The
little hypothetical you threw out a minute ago,
if you could only do one thing. If I had
to choose one thing, I'd choose email. Now,
I have 2 million email subscribers, so maybe
that's kind of an obvious choice. But even if
it was smaller, I would spend time building the
audience and building the email list because it
does so many things that are helpful. As you're
building the list, as you're as writing each week,
you're refining your ideas, you're
learning what resonates with people,
you're figuring out what your best concepts are.
And all of that can inform writing a better book,
which puts you in a better position. And then
you're also building the audience along the way.
And so now you have people that you can launch to.
If I had to pick one thing that, like let's say
your book's coming out in five months
and you don't have an email list,
but you have a book that's written, what would
I do? Then I would focus externally and I would
probably just try to do as many podcasts as
possible and use your current advantages to
achieve and gain new advantages. Right now, your
main advantage is time. You got five months,
how are you going to spend it? And then if you
can knock it out of the park with one podcast,
now you have a really good episode, maybe you can
get that published right away and you can send it
to some other shows that are like one level up and
prove that you're worthy to come on as a guest.
Then you try to knock those out of the park and
then if you have a really good one, you use that
and send it to the next level up and so on. And
you just kind of try to keep going like that.
So I would do email first, but if I didn't
have an email list, I think I'd pick podcast.
Tim Ferriss: How many Instagram
followers would it take,
if any, for you to give up your email list?
James Clear: Oh.
Tim Ferriss: So let's say, yeah, so 10
million? 20 million? What would the minimal
compelling number be, if there is one?
James Clear: I don't think I would do
it. It would have to be over 100 million. I
don't know that I would do it, because I —
Tim Ferriss: Say more.
James Clear: I'm not in
control of it. So Instagram can be, the algorithm
can change. My account could get suspended. They
could whatever. I don't write about provocative
stuff, but you get the idea. I'm not in control.
If you had 100 million followers, also, I'm
assuming some level of engagement here. It's
not just phantom followers. You're assuming
that you've got an engaged audience either way.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. If Kim
Kardashian were like, "I want you
to co-post on my Instagram with me."
James Clear: Yeah. She's like, "I'll
give you all my Instagram followers.
You give me all your email list."
Tim Ferriss: "We'll do makeup and booty
fitting dresses, and then, we'll have habits."
James Clear: Right. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: "You get every Wednesday."
James Clear: I know. My next book is Booty Habits.
Tim Ferriss: It would sell,
just saying.
James Clear: I'm telling
you, man. That sounds like a bestseller to me.
Tim Ferriss: You'd have to do more squats,
but that's okay.
James Clear:
Yeah. I don't know. There's obviously some
number where it'd be stupid not to do it, but
I don't know. Email's just so
flexible in how you can use it,
and Instagram is pretty constrained. It's got to
be an image. And I don't post images of myself.
Tim Ferriss: I'm in a similar
boat. If somebody said,
"I'll give you a 50 million." I wouldn't trade.
I'll give just a tip for folks also. This is what
I did with the first book and pretty much every
book since. If I'm sending out advanced copies,
I will send out galleys in some cases,
at least with the earlier books I did,
because it allowed me to just have a longer lead
time. I have very long books, as many people know.
They violate every rule of length. They tend to
be gigantic. And it takes a while for people to
explore these books. So I will send out galleys.
Usually, they're pretty much in final form. Maybe,
there are a few citations, no appendix,
probably no page numbers in the table of
contents, because that stuff is moving around.
But otherwise, they're pretty solid. They will not
have a final cover, as an example. But what I will
do, if I'm sending out advanced copies, whether
they're galleys or actual final product is, and
this is very old fashioned and it takes time, but
I feel like, if people skip some of these time
consuming steps on the front end, they are
sacrificing a lot of long-term potential. Because
they may not ever reach that escape velocity.
Get some Post-it Notes and pick specific
chapters or sections, so that you can say,
"if you don't have time to read the whole book,
and I don't expect you to read the whole book,
I tabbed the chapter that I think is going to
be most interesting to you or that might be
most interesting to you," which requires you to do
some homework, like you did when you were sending
pitches to these podcasts. You had so-and-so on.
You talked about A, B, and C. It seemed like your
audience really responded well to X. "Why don't
we do A, B, and C? Or if you'd be open to A, B,
and C." And that due diligence pays incredible
dividends. And what you did with podcasts
was exactly what I did for bloggers for
The 4-Hour Workweek. I microserialized,
so I could offer different blogs, different
places, like Life Hacker and so on, exclusives on
a particular facet of the book. And that required
an incredible amount of research on the front end.
James Clear: Yep, it's worth it. I did the same
thing for the sending out the advanced copies.
I can remember sending a message to Naval and
saying, "Hey, I know you're super busy. I do
genuinely think you'll find the book interesting.
If you only have time to read three pages,
I think these are the three to read." And I have
no idea if he read it or not, but he was like,
"Thanks, I got it." And so, that was it. And
it takes a long time to do it in that way. But
actually writing real emails to the podcasters and
not just doing a template and actually selecting
the pages that you think will be most useful for
each advanced copy and not just spray and pray,
that stuff, it helps. It actually works.
Tim Ferriss: And also, if you're being
very deliberate and very thoughtful about how you
are picking these recipients, oftentimes, it only
takes one or two. So doing that diligence
and research on the front end increases the
likelihood of you at least having one or two hits.
James Clear: I actually think the word that you
just used, which is "thoughtful," that's the
word that I come back to again and again and
that I actually hope that's the primary lesson
that people take away from this portion of the
conversation, talking about writing Atomic
Habits and talking about deconstructing the
marketing of it and the launch of it. I don't
know. Maybe, some people will be like, "Oh,
this sounds like a lot of marketing or whatever."
But I don't think about it that way at all.
I hope what comes through is that what I'm
trying is that, at each level of this experience,
the research of the product, the creation of the
book, the launch, and the marketing of the book,
I'm trying to be as thoughtful as possible,
to create the most compelling or most useful
version of the book, to share the best examples
in the book, to find and identify the people who
will be the best fit for the book, and to deliver
it to them in a way that is the most thoughtful
and makes it as easy as possible for them to
consume the book and share it with others.
And if you're thoughtful at each stage of that
process, you're just going to end up with such
a better outcome. And if you are just trying
to write a book, but get it out there quickly,
because you want to have a book, you don't want to
write a book. Or if you're just trying to market
it and get it to as many people as possible,
because you want to have a popular book,
you don't really care about who it is that it
resonates with. If you cut corners like that,
then it is just really hard to have a great
outcome. But if you're thoughtful at each
stage, then it tends to work out much better.
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent agreed. Coming back to
the frameworks and principles in Atomic Habits,
are there any sections, chapters, principles,
anything, that you wish more people paid
attention to? There's something that you put in,
that gets glossed over or maybe doesn't stick,
for whatever reason, as much as other things,
but you think it, or these things, are important.
I certainly have examples from my books, where I'm
like, "Shit, I don't know if I made a mistake in
the way I presented that, but it's not getting
its fair shake in the sense of its importance."
James Clear: Well, sometimes, you might just be
like, "Maybe I thought that idea
was better than it actually was."
Tim Ferriss: There might be that too.
James Clear: Yeah, I have a couple. So there are
two things that came to mind. The first one is,
there's a little example I give in the book about,
maybe about halfway through or 40 percent through,
where I talk about having a pre-game routine and
doing things in the same sequence each time,
in the same order each time. And that helps
get you in the mindset and kind of initiate the
habit. So I played baseball through college,
and I had the same pre-game routine that I did
before each game. And that kind of flips this
switch in your mind, where it's like, "Hey,
it's time to compete now. It's game mode."
Or the example I gave in the book was this
guy who, he would do his writing at the
library and he would go to the library,
sit at the same desk each day, and put
on his headphones and play the same playlist.
And that little sequence was a pre-game routine,
that got him in the mindset to do his writing
habit. And one day, he turned around and realized
that no music was playing, he just had his
headphones on, and it was just silent. But
he was writing, and he was 20 minutes into writing
before he realized it. And it's a good example of
how just that sequence of doing it the same way
each time and having that same pre-game routine,
that little ritual, got him in the mindset. He
didn't even need to press play that day. He was
just ready to write. And so, if you can come up
with what that little pre-game ritual is for you,
that can be a great way to initiate a habit. And I
don't usually see people talk about that. I think,
actually, I've heard some examples like
this on your podcast previously, Tim,
I think, when you talked to Josh Waitzkin at
one point. Sometime, he gave this example,
maybe it was in his books, maybe it was a
conversation with you, where he was competing
in this national competition, martial arts.
And he was told that he was going to compete
at one time, and they came up to him and he was
sleeping or laying on a bench. And they were like,
"Hey, sorry, timing was wrong. You're actually
up in six minutes." And he was like, "Normally,
I would've been thrown off." But he had
this little pre-game ritual that he did,
and he tried to, as he developed it over time, it
started out and maybe it was 10 minutes and then,
he tried to compress it. So it was seven
minutes and then, it was three minutes.
And then, eventually, got it down to where his
little ritual was just something he did for 30
seconds. And so, they woke him up on that bench,
and he's got to compete six minutes later. But
all he needed was 30 seconds to get in the
right frame of mind. And then, he was like,
"Okay, now I'm ready to go." And so, those
pre-game rituals can be really powerful if you
make it your own and come up with something
that you do every time and it helps get you
into the mindset to compete or to perform.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure. Josh has given,
could be, his personal example. He's also talked
about Marcelo Garcia, who's nine-time world
champion Brazilian jiu jitsu, arguably, maybe
uncontroversially, probably, one of the best, if
not the best, who's ever competed in Brazilian jiu
jitsu, who has a similar ability to throw a switch
minutes before he'll compete in a world
championship ballot. And it applies furthermore
to most writers who I have had on the podcast,
will have some type of boot up sequence,
much like this person who went to the library. And
people can take solace in the fact that there's no
consensus. There's no consensus.
James Clear: It's very personal,
and you need to make it your own.
Tim Ferriss: And there are also people who will
say, "Yeah, I just dick around for the first two
hours, but that's not wasted time because it takes
that long for me to just scribble or complain
about my day on the page, so that I'm filling
the page with something and then it turns into an
hour later, some paragraph that is the nugget of
the beginning of what I need to work on that day."
James Clear: Eventually, the pain of not doing
it becomes greater than the pain
of doing it. And they take action.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Or Neil Gaiman and he is like,
"Yeah, I'd go to the cabin and I don't have to
write, but I'm not allowed to do anything else."
James Clear: I'd love that. I love that.
That's great.
Tim Ferriss:
And B.J. Novak also has his own approach.
He's done a ton of television and film work.
And for me, right now, we're working on fiction
for the first time over the last, let's call it,
six months, finding the routine, how I make the
coffee, when I sit down, the exact sequence,
how I set up my laptop on the laptop stand. It's
very monkish, but it does make a big difference.
So that was one. The pre-game sequence.
James Clear: Yeah. So developing a pre-game
ritual that works for you. And then, the other
one that I feel like this is something that,
if I had to pick a topic that I feel like is more
important than I realized when I was writing the
book, I would probably say this, and that's the
power of the social environment. We are all part
of multiple tribes. Sometimes, those tribes are
large, like what it means to be American. And
sometimes, they're small, like what it means to
be a neighbor on your street or a member of the
local gym. But all of those tribes that you belong
to, the large groups and the small groups, they
all have this set of expectations. They've got a
set of social norms for what you do when you're
in that group and what the typical way is to act
and behave and what kind of habits they follow.
And the more that your habits go with the grain of
the expectations of the group, the more attractive
they feel like to you, because it's like, "Hey,
I fit in. I belong. I'm part of something."
And the more that they go against the grain of the
expectations of the group, the harder they are to
stick to, especially in the long run. Maybe you
can do it for a day or a week or, I don't know,
a month or two, but at some point, you kind of
keep rubbing against, you have this friction where
you're conflicting with the group. And it becomes
hard to stick to that for the long run. And so,
the little takeaway that I kind of think of
now is you want to join groups, to join tribes,
where your desired behavior is the normal
behavior. Because if it's normal in that group,
then it becomes really motivating to stick to it.
And furthermore, the kind of ancillary habits that
are part of that group, the other expectations,
are things that you're probably going to soak up.
People will join a CrossFit gym because they
think they want to get in shape. But then,
you turn around, six months later, and they're
all eating paleo and wearing the same brand
knee sleeves and they buy the same workout gear
and it's all these other habits that they never
intended to build. But they just kind of soaked
them up, because that's what the group was doing.
And ultimately, I think this comes back to
this kind of deep need that we all have,
which is this need to bond and connect.
We all want to be a part of something.
We want to belong. We want to fit in. And if
people have to choose between "I have habits
that I don't really love, but I fit in, I
belong, I'm part of something," or "I have
the habits that I want to have, but I'm cast out,
I'm ostracized, I'm criticized," most of the time,
the desire to belong will overpower the
desire to improve. So as best as possible,
you've got to get those two things aligned
and surround yourself with people where your
desired behavior is the normal behavior.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely. The whole
you are the average of the five people you
associate with most type of thinking. And also,
for people who are starting off the new
year or about to, and thinking about
how to best ensure that you
cohere with a group, that
leads to these new behaviors, front load it,
make it painful not to do it. Pay in advance,
make some type of bet with one of your friends,
and you owe each other money if you miss workouts.
Set it up so it is painful not to do it. I know
that might sound like I'm favoring the stick over
the carrot. You're also going to use the carrots.
You can use the carrots, but make it compelling
from an incentives perspective to do it.
James Clear: And as you said, you can also
use the carrots. The flip side of that is, so
yes, make it painful not to do it and make it
easy and frictionless and obvious to do it. Try
to design your environments, so the things that
you say are important to you are the obvious and
available things. I think one interesting thing
you can do is just think about one habit you're
trying to build and then walk into the rooms where
you spend most of your time each day. Kitchen,
office, bedroom, whatever. And just look around
and ask yourself, "what behaviors are obvious
here? What is this space designed to encourage?"
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's really good.
James Clear: You'll start to notice different
things that you can tweak to make the good habit
more obvious and easier and the bad habits,
or the things you want to avoid, less obvious
and maybe a little higher friction. And making
one or two little adjustments like that is not
going to radically transform your life. But if
you make a dozen or two dozen or 50 and you're
kind of all of these environments, all these
rooms where you're spending space each day are
primed to support the habits you want to build,
now you've got a tailwind rather than a headwind.
And so, it's become so much easier to appear as
if you have great willpower or that you're really
consistent, when really, you're benefiting from
the environment that you already set up.
Tim Ferriss: And I'll also say, sometimes,
one or two changes can make a huge difference.
Coming back to my brownie binge yesterday.
There's a reason I don't cook brownies all the
time. There's a reason I don't have chips in
my house, because I will eat all the fucking
chips. I will eat everything. I love chips.
And rather than view that as a failing, yes, I
could take the hard path and crawl on my knees
through broken glass to develop the willpower to
stare at these chips every day and not eat them,
or I can just not have the chips in my pantry.
James Clear: Put yourself in positions to succeed.
A lot of it is positioning. If you have a dog and
you're walking it down the street and your dog
doesn't get along well with other dogs and you see
one coming toward you, go to the other side of the
street. Don't put the dog in a bad situation. That
kind of thing is obvious with our pets or with our
friends or our family members. We're like, "Oh,
why would you do that to yourself?" And then,
we do it to ourselves all the time. So try to
design a space where you are being served by your
environment, rather than being hindered by it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. I think it was,
I don't want to misquote them, but when I had
Jerry Seinfeld on this show, I think he said
something like, "Your mind is a stupid little
dog that you have to train," something along
those lines. And if you think about it,
I think, now, you got me on dog training,
I think about dog training a lot. And I trained
my dog, Molly, and took it super seriously and
worked with all these different trainers and
then, tried to modify it and so on. Surprise,
surprise. And there are these basic things,
where it's like, if you talk to somebody and
they have a problem because their dog chews
shoes, as an example. And you can ask, "Well,
where did the dog spend most of its time for its
first two months in the house as a puppy?" And
they'll be like, "Oh, he ran around the house."
And be like, "Well, did you have shoes on the
floor?" "Yes." And that's how the dog developed a
habit of chewing on shoes. But if you crate train
your dog and you simply prevent them from
chewing on shoes for the first few months,
they're not going to eat shoes.
It's just not going to be a thing,
generally speaking. And for humans too, it's
like, if you don't want to eat chips every day,
Tim Ferriss, then don't leave the shoes on the
floor. Don't leave the chips on the pantry.
This is a solvable problem. So I find a lot of
reassurance in the fact that it doesn't have to be
brute force willpower. And I'm not saying this
to you, because in place of something nebulous
like that, you can set up systems and you can
also rank order your habits in such a way that
you are looking for the upstream habits,
that make the downstream habits easier.
So whenever I've wanted to get in better
shape or someone has asked me for advice,
they're like, "What should I eat?"
And I'm like, "Let's talk about
exercise first." Because if you eat well,
it doesn't necessarily lead to exercise,
but if you exercise very often, you're not going
to want to spoil the exercise you did by eating a
bunch of crap. If you exercise and you're like,
"Wow, I put in a lot of effort, I feel great,"
you're going to have this sunk cost
fallacy benefit of having put in that
effort and you'll be less inclined to screw it
up. There'll be too much cognitive dissonance.
And in making those types of decisions, you
can actually make behavioral change a lot
easier for yourself. And I'm also looking at my
environment. I'm like, "Coffee, coffee, coffee,
coffee, coffee." So if I want to reduce my
coffee consumption, maybe I should change
this room that I spend so much time in.
Oh, my goodness. Anything else that you
would like to say, James? We've been going now for
almost three hours, and I think this is
probably a good place to begin to wind down.
But is there anything else you'd like to mention?
James Clear: The trajectory of your life bends in
the direction of your habits. And a lot of
what we've talked about today, whether it's
launching a book or writing a book, whether it's
building an exercise habit or a meditation habit,
growing an email list or developing a creative
habit, it comes back to consistency. It comes
back to doing small things well each day,
trying to live one good day, and then,
waking up again tomorrow and doing the same
thing. And the world is very results oriented,
and that's fine. We all want to get better
results, but almost all the results that you want
are a lagging measure of your habits. So your bank
account is a lagging measure of your financial
habits. Your physical fitness is a lagging
measure of your training habits. Even silly stuff,
like the amount of clutter in your living room,
is a lagging measure of your cleaning habits.
So if you want your results to change, the
habits that proceed them are the things
that actually need to change. It's like fix the
inputs, and the outputs will fix themselves. And
I don't think that means you have to be radical
about it. It doesn't mean that you have to upend
your entire life. Really, all you need to do is
focus on having five good minutes. You can do a
lot with five good minutes. Five good minutes of
exercise can reset your mood. Five good minutes
of conversation can restore a relationship.
Five good minutes of writing can make you
feel great about the manuscript again. And so
it doesn't take much to feel good, to get back
on the path, to continue to make progress.
And small habits, showing up in little ways,
mastering the art of showing up, trying to get a
little bit better each day, those are all things
that you can keep in mind as you try to just live
one good day today and be on a good trajectory.
And that really one of the core ideas of Atomic
Habits is getting one percent better today.
And it's really about that. It's not about
measuring it, and "that is a one-percent
improvement," or 1.6 percent, or whatever. It's
not about the numbers. It's like a mindset. It's
a philosophy, it's an approach, that "I'm
going to focus on the trajectory that I'm
on and I'm going to try to stay on a good path,
even if it's just in small ways," and then,
trust that that will compound and multiply and
turn into something much greater over time.
Because the truth is, time will magnify whatever
you feed it. If you have good habits, time becomes
your ally, and all you need is patience. But if
you have bad habits, time becomes your enemy. And
every day that goes by, you kind of dig the hole
a little bit deeper. And so, the ideas in Atomic
Habits, the strategies for making small changes,
for letting these behaviors improve over time,
it's all about getting time to work for you. And I
think you can start in really small ways and begin
to reinforce your desired identity. And hopefully,
this time next year, you'll be really happy with
where you're at in the progress you've made.
Tim Ferriss: Hear, hear. I'm not going to
spoil that with adding any commentary that
is unnecessary. I think that's a strong way
to close. James Clear, you can find him at
jamesclear.com. On Twitter and Instagram,
@JamesClear, will link to everything including the
3-2-1 Newsletter, which everyone should check out
in the show notes, as per usual, tim.blog/podcast.
James, thanks so much for taking the time. This is
great. Took a ton of notes. I have homework.
I have changes to make. I have perhaps a few
bags of coffee to remove from my immediate
space. And this has rekindled my enthusiasm,
amplified my enthusiasm for the new year. So I
appreciate you sharing so much and being so game
to play the tennis match of this conversation.
James Clear: Of course. Thanks,
Tim. Really appreciate it, man.
Tim Ferriss: And to everybody listening, be
just a little bit kinder than is necessary today.
That includes to yourself. Setup systems. Remember
our dear friend, Arken Locus, we will not rise to
the level of our goal or our hopes, but fall to
the levels of our training and our systems. So
best of luck to you, and thanks for tuning in.